[music]
good afternoon good evening dear friends
today unfortunately with such a serious
late but still start direct
broadcast of the first day of the final part
final grand tour in london
we managed to break into the live broadcast
Is Yevgenia Miroshnichenko still with you or
measures of Skripchenko and let's immediately
we'll probably look at
to the draw and on the desk at the final
already lost and in this match for the third
a place where unexpectedly plays
magna scales
yes, well, yes, now we have to
a little like this in turbo mode
catch up and so your kilos off
Dean's playing the finals I'll remind Dean's
semi-finals had no problems beat
the area is quite confident, but the war
kilograms with carlson right there
epic turned out confrontation and
Maxim has won in rapid chess for
tie-break stages at the break stage
the main let's say the main match after
in all games played will end in
draw
leads with a big score maxim head
logrov classic vs denali same her
five wins with one loss 9 draws in
grante sture both games ended
a draw completely unexpected for me
the stats are so devastating
in classic dresses yes but still
let's not forget that maxim
older and I think these are the first
confrontation let's say it was maxim's
roles and la favorita yes and
but nonetheless a good score for maxim
definitely yes in the match for third place
let me remind you, here he shows us maxims
kilograms and denali are not there already
quite a few things happened
we remind you what an interesting match for
the third place here the guys have already played
among themselves in the classics 16 wins to all
lesions at 39 not
them it's 62 park turns between each other
played magnus carlsson or won aronian
no wonder magus plus magus
plus with virtually all chess players
modernity, yes, I don’t remember
I think the only one we remembered
who has a positive score in the classics
with Magnus Carlsen probably all the same
managed to catch up come on
Let us remind our viewers
tournament format and what a classic
the game is still given by 6 points, yes
once again we remind you of the format 2 classics
played until today first game tomorrow
respectively 2 6 points for a victory in
classical game and on the third day
the most intense play out the most
games will be played with the most points
two games of rapid chess 25 minutes
delay of 10 seconds and four batches per
blitz for winning quickly and is given 4 points for
win blitz 2
we'll be back anyway come on come on
look at the party i suggest to start with
final, well, firstly, because this is the final
secondly, because there is much more
the moves have already been made and the position starts like this
not only let's say so to be determined yes well
and it seems to me a little emasculated
although you can probably talk about some
advantage of black waters current position
on the board now
Refresh a couple more moves have been made by me
right now black one for some reason
movement has not yet played will figure it out 6
it is very logical to assume that
on foot from 6 will be taken surrender to 8
6 will be born
bishop to 8 bishop b6 3 options because
pawn c6 looks like yes nowhere to run away
let's see let's do it
a small review of the debut
variant yes what was it at all and so
played the Spanish game d3 short
castling from the moon 7 yes and here 6 move
up to 3 which are quite popular
now is
Well, probably due to the fact that not quite
white understand what to do with a counterattack
marshal
after water and one short castling bb5
castling we know we've seen
that the dean is playing the marshal's counterattack and he
elected in the World Cup final against
Timur Radjabov and I think here
somewhere in rapid chess already managed
play from another country option for 3
very often used here
French chess second
Maxim Wax Gram And Tenba Crossa
game this option they are very much it
analyzed
made a great contribution to the theory there
a lot of interesting ideas and he certainly
also often found at the highest level
and the main idea is of course to play a3 a3
before
keep the bishop from being traded after the knight
again and leave the elephant but diagonally a
two 8 let's say this is perhaps the main
difference compared to the move from 23 to
more so more spanish something is
White is standing a pawn on a3, she displays c3
horse and as far as I remember in this variant
not one or two whole party straight already
the story of Maxim's duel with a lemon a ranya
us their time were plenty enough
games have already played short castling
horse c3 well and here if I don't
am I mistaken he played bishop g4 this is one of
the main continuations, yes, or something
new blame for a new vision before
a more modern direction is
still horses again and
Bishop e6 this is also already
debuted with her not once or twice
but again it was met in the finger
dinli himself
Zhenya he played in the seventeenth year against
magnus end on
in san luis and what exactly is in the party
against magnus and despite the fact that it
was rapid chess
Magnus went for the option reported on 2
Let's try to explain a little
all the same, it happens here after b4 if
the knight retreats to c6 what white does
horse 5 jump yes eat enough
unpleasantly it turns out 5 then somehow here
4 will support . c6
black problem in spanish before cavalry 6
not everyone understands do therefore white
first, that is, vice versa, black first
break on a2 move knight c6
here follows the elephant same 5 this too
met several times after the move
queen d8 d7 it seems to me that something is here
here to the end I don't understand why
it is the queen b7 and there are some others
moves were made by white trying to bring in
this option player positions where they have you
there is only one good horse against the bad one
char floor elephant that is they are in
Ideally, they want to change horses and bring
position well again let's look at
into different structures after just
janson and really exchange words
on f6 they put the knight up to the 5th here
interesting moment black moves a6 again
without much fear of double pawns because
as I understand the horse in the boss
before weakness of bullets occurs 5 but in
whole black ready to cover his move
horse and this, yes, on the next move it
maybe after a 4-ku we carry again
White can take on f6, especially this
no one does it mentioned
elmira party carlson vs 1 or else
not me from rapid chess was played
get along 2 and where the movement fails
reacted to this show magnus
corsa must on we stay with your party
kilogram division is a let's see
one last try here to improve the game
black in this position
what happens if it's black
they go to this structure associated with
of course, but you need to leave the salon 8 you
Do you want to still show the scale to everyone
by mouth
Motylev Alexander there and nipples because
I'm really interested in
these positions are very complex password
alexander model found a moth
alexander tomashevsky sheepskin name
Eugene and in Russian I correct
a Frenchwoman and the world, yes, because in
Russian name still before candy wrappers
I didn’t have time, but the most interesting thing for me
what nuances does the stomach hold and
White's strategy yes, well, that's curious
really if we return to the position
that is, a bunch of parks where black people go
a6 again, don't pay attention, but
phenomena, Tomashevsky retreated like an elephant on
daewoo xing and in general also like us
it seemed no problems after ti4
now on silk do not eat it did not go
we carry here I was thinking why no one herself
knight d4 here it was interesting knight d4
went to change this knight if white
exchanged yes apparently then black
they kick out quality and you don't have dessert usa
don't get pissed off trine 3 so gave a horse
some kind of undefined fate
after that pretty up to 5 may inherent
in danger so I think
quite right alexandrov went to her
three in this position 4 horses details here
knight f3 also exchange a pair of knights for
black let's go add 5 here they want
on the contrary, change the elephants of fire and
to replay such a simply hard curly
blizzard hairpin
well, here we have a party made
wife and again with 4-ku not all of us are here
that's maxim quite a lot of time
spent and made a move first q 1b 3
which is looking ahead of
the further development of the parties looks
rather unconvincingly black
react b5 beats 4 now in this
the moment I decided to exchange for e7, I
I understand that in the case of dc it is already possible to beat
on d5 beat on b4
go somewhere al offers b5 rook b8 then
there is a pawn on b4 weak but no less
weak black on c6 hardly black
they play for an advantage and there are special problems
should not be tested after dc maxim
exchanged for and 7 first and no
wait bc bc till exchanged for and 7 dc
bb
black moves heart 6 attacks the pawn
e4
and this is the situation with the knight on f3 and
2 Sochi pawns and 4 she seems to me in
some Sicilian arises quite
often
Disappearing service 5 universal in find
fits with knight on f3 after and 5
and acacias that whites are very uncomfortable and
protect because on horseback 2 is
elephant 5 some problems arise
so here white will play owning one
after which the exchange for 28 and calmly
same 7 same 6 somewhere getting ready to play f5 yes
where it can be just done
black queen's move I'll go c6 well, that is, according to
Feeling black is no problem now
Maxim played b5, it seems to me that it's worth it
fix in this position structures then
that of course I want to transfer the horse to
d5 very slow it all looks on
it seems on a horse t-22 horse one horse you
just follow forza 4 to 1 and behind
black yes it is natural to play the queen
4 maybe an elephant 5 first maybe
be aired for 4 immediate in general not
it seems that white ever takes risks here
put the knight on d5 so max
we see on and would play 5 at once to
prevent queen 4 then black move
heart 5 on some awkward move and
have to do spheres dream 2 is coming over
heart 6 bc and at this moment and so
a little confused as to what it means
why didn't they take us 6 black-black
play until the elephant from md80 that maxim
knight answers d2
he still goes to the translation plan
yes horse and
maybe on b3 the knight goes to sit again
somehow drop a pawn did not know hide and seek
of course, well, here is the question yes, that is it
scrapping b6 as White answers, that is, either
still trying to horse one suspecting
that heart six sooner or later need
yes kunya 3 put the knight on d5 she is alone
out of the possibilities
yes, well, here she really has three
very unpleasant elephant 2 3 3 5 take
with a rook for checkmate and dad should take
f.u.
and despite the heavy curly endings
and White's limited material can
be big problems because heap
frenzied weakness
that is, they still go to max on b3 with the knight on
scrapped in 6 first beats 6
played but here is the question
is it really possible to hold c5
whether to drop the pawn with c5 because
if it doesn't work out so for black
you just know better that's what you mentioned
about the results of the last match between maxim
Axis to the gram and Magnus Colson you
you know, and there it reminds me a little
to win against the minotaur because
Maxim defeated Magnus but maybe
gave all his strength to this knowing
next match already you play a little bit
in a mode in which you just try
go on some self-preservation
and get lost already somewhere in the rapid blitz
not so easy all the same yielded oh yeah
of course overpowered to happen in the first place
I don’t really remember who topped this minotaur
about this to the epic but it burns out there
seems to me the most logical debut from
possible being in london he plays
london's where to give the minotaur we
called Magnus Carlsen I don't know
did he deserve
Norwegian is such a nickname, well, in general
party magnus anti wounded there
the london system is played here
offering one move to look
rook and one-on-one
here you are probably right
correctly note that trying to maximize
minimize losses or something yes, well, here
minimize risks where one probably
after the exchange Black should not have enough
resources yes, although I think that it is unlikely
there are doubts that black
a more pleasant board for him by one tone with
some kind of weakness on f2 but also on black
there are no figures left, yes there is nothing left
get on the other side
leave the open line and go somewhere
rook is also a bit counterintuitive
maybe ok 8 need to try
come on while we move on to the party magna
Soapy I welcome all chat and remind
of course you and our official
hashtags we should appear on
screen
our official hash is the same
face often new dis oh oh nose also
we managed to restore connections on youtube
and on our official website
chester dot org hello everyone in the chat
I'm just grateful to all of our
fans and we waited for us too
we miss you and I see that questions have already gone
but first let's analyze
still the part of magnus
so difficult for us
comforting such a fight for
consolation third place between Magnus
koleso new or you hurt us they
are, it seems to me, all the same
unaccustomed to
positions for the magus, for sure yes, that is
magnus who plays in the match for third
their place in the final is so unusual
home a little surprising well recall
that there is still a significant difference in
prizes between fourth and third place
so what yes in fact it is possible to
treat it if you
pragmatic such a point of view yes it is
20 thousand dollars to be drawn
here in the match for three days 20 thousand dollars
difference last fourth place in this
tournament
it's 43 already 60 and so played the london
the so-called date system 4 elephant and 4
e3 and so on
c5 e3 knight c6 knight b2 this position
played many times
played by black in a variety of ways
whites have what's good in the London system
whites don’t seem to have to think, yes then
have you come out on the recorded chain you want
I am 33 years old
everything is schematic but it is not enough
presses and because very often she
leads to such seemingly equal
structures but where are black
others are just the slightest kontra games and such
positions again against magnus to play
with all hello so here's the move ferris
more there would like to point out what is wrong
often make him white answer
someone was shaking already 4 here with us
Almira I had a discussion while trying
restore the stream because all the same
there is some reason to continue
h2 h3 it seems to me that these positions are very
important to understand
the meaning of the slightest entry is why h3
for example, it seems to me that they are immediately 4
because whites are trying to deprive
black opportunities to play knight h5 here
what happened in our party come on
let's see what it can lead to
exclude some options too
ok let's see how the cake is all the same
interpreted the mogu position a4 a6
Well, I'm curious what if
answering again is completely for blacks
closes the slightest possibility
play on the queenside until layer p5
then for about three
if the bishop does not take on e3 poking 5 to
i.e. rather a6 than black again
should react is almost wrong
here after again in most cases
most of the parties that met
maybe not this particular position but
something like black still receded
on q 8 levon decided to go queen 7 c 23 and
family 6 bishop e2 such a calm move
feeling true whites spend temporarily
this is if we look at what's in
parties further turned out after and 6 did not
it is quite clear why not play h2 h3
here already because let's say the case
bishop and 3 queens 3
bishop e7 bishop d3 castling short
short castling turns out something
very similar to the position in the party only
Feels like with a couple of sleepy x's extra
tempo whites because let's
let's see what happened
sent me two black cloud fabric h5 elephant
e3 queen d8 moves towards and on f4 white
now play h3 pro you know or world a
you're still not only white time
spent but also Black moved the knight h5
back, that is, it is difficult to say how much
exactly the pace who lost the elephant to 6
londa 3 short short right here
curious because I would like to say
wanted to play black no diary though
exchange lists of one of the bishops
so here is enough
the standard operation is to check
go elephants in 4mm
to be, too, could be considered a
here most likely I will go in this game
Wounds taken and take pawn lead e4
if immediately e5 of course does not call it
and it was according to the plan to play e5 right away
there is some danger here
la diabetes and in 6 sacrifice quality if
whites will have time to somehow settle down, let's say
queen d2 well, in general, yes, this is a separate
some kind of completely incomprehensible
at first glance position yes I might not
you come back after all a little debut
stage because I myself was
I wonder why, for example, on 4 black is not
go e6 it seems to me there is such
great idea
White, that is, on 5, what is the bishop b4
c3 bishop again and this is the move
interesting water will not come to mind from 3
judges middle win figures me
seems like such a great idea
opposition as a result it's even
2 grandmaster games happened after
elephant and in 3 it’s just what to show what’s what
bring a [ __ ], too, can still firs
up to 8 like where offers up to 8 but I take
horses again like they are again, that is, for 4
such a strange position to drive, well, it seems
not refuted 6 not fully understood
yes, I'm interested in putting 3 9
I saw it honestly, it seems to me that
maybe but he gave get funny
looks rook three stages queen 1 come on
listening is not necessarily that he is stronger yes
Of course, I just want to show
what is it possible to play it seems to me here
exactly two elephants, even without haste they
still compensate in this position
even a bad structure after like in 3g
well let's see what happened
party then here in the party we got here
the one with color change Carlsbad
structure yes as if again black
would play with white
queen's gambit and exchanged on d5 but in
in this case cd to d4 is short
castling ferris c7 rook one king
retreat our 8 and here is the queen f3
Well, what exactly is in these structures
in the Cossack
black always has the option
carry out a minority attack
more precisely, minorities here
version of so4 again, as it were, what is the plan here
and discarded he elects the next
plank two cases and 8
everyone switches to e5 in the form of bada
although after e5 Black almost always has
there will be at least some minimum
women strategic idea hold like
in french change char floor
elephants, it seems to me, well, there usually
remains a white horse and an elephant against an elephant
and here black has two knights, maybe
be this position already five icons same 8 here
so that you have a game on well somewhere as well
you don't want to after the same elephant 5
but the servants of all then apparently never again
you want yes
anaconda 7 probably something like that
disturbed here move queen h5 and h6 now
you can’t play white, they’ll just take us away
6 yes, that is, we need black 6
walk here
somehow there queen h4 for now yes that is and
same 6 not
not the most desired indulgence
kingside
so horse livin sen easing stroller
fangs are always below 18 to have
opportunity h6 I will say queen move 5d
what do the blacks themselves want and here I am
wondered what positions exist and
such a day seems to me connected with their 5
back knight f6 knight f6 to her four
really as soon as killed them played
h2 expects but will say use in
some version if Black goes to 5
come back to them on and at 6 put it on
and 4
it will be very difficult from this horse
get rid of it because
attack the knight e4 pawn f3 create yourself
here's a bunch of those char outdoor weaknesses
on the kingside
at least uncomfortable for whites and look
again, if on b3 ahmad despite something
like a pawn again and fixes the queen
flank on the other side of the river on b3
tied to protection so just him and not
you would like to bring him somewhere
connect there
like this on a royal sledge
just a minute I want it like this
kingside or
same be him would be his 25 want
put it here I don't know when
like in the variant again come on
we'll be back I can't show what was
opportunity to close bishop c7
that's why we ran so fast through
debuts the moment when after the horse already
when its he went to nyash 5 we did or
I'll let you know this is an opportunity right there
after all, the scientists on the left had the opportunity
play sun si and get better 8 tons b6
such a life and the queen himself d8 already
sick or play up to an elephant and in 3 like
at 3 knight f6 black here
candy 7 seems to threaten it is possible
play coincidir we like this like this
quite curious this structure yes
because the bishop is on b6
it seems like not yet there is no possibility of it
exchange it is not clear what he is doing there
but somehow cements the queenside and I
I suspect after castling somewhere and there
actual games with c34 may arise
could of course such a position is obtained
but then again let's see here is magnus
quite a curious move makes plays
rook e1 and e2 curious from what point
view that kind of like owning one then not
threatens up all the same that he parries
then I'm already so yeah okay but what
next move
killed boris i still glove you
super make the exit black in this
positions, it seems to me like this
position slightly spring accounted for
adapt to the plan and black and white
after end 8 what move up to 6 can be
determine the elephant walked start
I'm really
I don’t understand it’s clear what black should do
it would be nice to find something smarter
than give check to h2 and go back I don't
I really understand not much like white
planning to launch an offensive
either move the pawn forward or
what else can he do
raise here 3 king two before and
then as many as 4 maybe like this
gave 12 as prevention against 5
counts, although it is also possible here
still discuss let's say rook one first
everyone then everything then is already a pawn on 5 not
hanging and I'm all up elephants in what if all
probation at 4
and everything worked out for White and now
after exchanging chur outdoors you can f3
playing is not as weird as
says after the elephant can get you up to 6
such and maybe a crow as in a nursery
songs on don't know don't go the same king
compression x and if e5 suppose yes then
there are sold on d5 hangs probably on
most likely you can take over it not
especially yes, it’s not very clear why for what
given a pawn
what can we gracefully plays in principle
this type of position doesn't hold you very well
like move to handed teach move with
what 8 is not so easy to understand
be h6 some in the sense of the standard
here is double vision in and oddly enough in carba
grandpa just it's complicated what's in
there would be no ordinary in an ordinary carlsbad
pawns on again then got one side up
Black would have already deployed on the queen's
on the flank, but at the same time the h6-pawn would not be hanging
yes you suggest principle it includes
practice we lay down the retreat it is necessary 2 such
strange
the problem is that there are 5 to play not
maybe the knight f6 will come back for now
it’s impossible, that is, it gets stuck
knives 8 horse wanted to test a bit
why wanted part wanted to check
now the idea of ​​ce-5 here and on d5 somehow
attack knight f6
use but our native queen and
recedes yes and 4 there seems to be nothing
no, that is, simply, but if you take on d4
playing this position without haste is strange
Kanye is very clear whether there are killed 6 there
well, probably for unnecessary words beta 6
probably just a pawn and pick up bye
not to be there just the border of jumps
so that it doesn't feel like yes it does
will be just the position in which
killed a small
a slight loss of harmony, but at
this is an extra pawn, let it be completely clear
Yes, I'm hardly behind my brother queen-bishop than
then it seems to me that but if there is not yourself
you wanted to avoid these embarrassments
maybe you need to
exchange for it here and take it 4
that is, all the same, an extra pawn for extra
five white extra pawn and two bishops well
yes, that is completely incomprehensible, that is
doesn't seem like a comfortable situation for me
checked the status of life ratings and
after the victory on us on gathered maxim
finally it's a graph
came out on top in fast
chess in the world ranking
so here are the changes
occurred after the semi-final match with
how i dont understand
counted
well, it's because they don't have that
played a quick show more we were on
front window but forced them fast
chess played a draw
at the same time, maxim pressed 11 points, well then
there is this apparently for winning the thai match
break what's good for the tire is not
I should consider it seems to me
seems like a tie-break at all
as soon as it is not necessary
ongoing parties seem to me in general
not not not quite right to count these i
not quite because all the same what
brings you victory in the match for what
we then fight if we stop
all considers the view of the calculation of the rating
at least some responsibly everything should
still be in these parties
frivolity, well, I'm sorry they played me there
90 thousand dollars up to approx.
the difference between winning and losing in
this boy is not here it seems to me
it just distorts with our how
discussed in team competitions that
no need to calculate the rating is also by
in my opinion absolutely fair because
what starts when these replacements
someone to play eight consecutive parties
black yes it's not about team
competitions when you have a team there
plus one stands on you in good
positions say draw yes that is
here it is here and here probably all the same
also because look good Magnus
suppose he lost the first second he
forced to play to win there whatever
no matter what, and in such a situation, then
there you are under such pressure that the principle
draw and defeat are the same
also probably not quite right
1 but be that as it may, the maxim goes to
first line faster than we do it and
congratulations one is not that much to me
further in my opinion yes he is too
also due to the victory of the most convincing 20
in rapid chess over a lemon is wounded
well, what shows the care of the ram, you need something
happens in the finger of the maxim there
evaded the exchange of the rook now we
we also want to switch there
recall the time control in classic y
us 2 hours 10 minutes at the very beginning of the park
given and no extra already
add 30 seconds delay yes
if the move is made faster than 30 seconds then
time is not wasted, but sometimes it is
leads to such interesting things as
let's say to such an interesting route
time what a very busy position
immediately after the debut, that's just Carson and
Aronian yes, that is, they are already equal in
an hour wasted an hour wasted to
reach this position if further
such a voltage is no counting
such a position would not arise if
further maneuver fire maneuver we can
wait for 10 minutes left and
only then will the crisis begin will give me
wanted to return to the match
maxim vegetables rogoff i still again
I've known him for a long time, I follow him
I analyzed a lot of results
some even a trend in his
results it almost always
stumbles precisely in the final matches
I don't know what's going on here
this moment but he was losing the most important
tie-break and match for first place
selected for the candidate
contender tournament
almost all matches for first place
lost in French, as it were
psychology there is such a term
polydor was so famous
cyclist very much over himself
worked showed brilliant results
but something prevented him from becoming
really brilliant cyclists
win the Tour de France and how would
what is a french bulldog expression
chess polydor is not so rare anymore
applied to maxim me just
I would like to know if he can
it is unlikely for them to break in this game
will be able to break here begins
stably, yes, I wanted to shine
also knowledge of French if I stop
lidor so you don't doubt it for
golden hen
betrayed or yes and I hope that maxim
done work on myself I think
exactly work, well, honestly for maxims
not
does not impress a person
who will do the work
psychology on over your psychology here
I think he is so
focused on chess
here is a man who believes that everything
you can decide on the board, I'm not saying that
this is correct, but this is how to communicate with
something and of course its much better
you know, but it seems to me that all the same
very concentrated names on chess
problems, that is, it is better to patch up
debut something else what are you completely
right, this again characterizes him
US . from the point of view that it fits
he has a more scientific approach
to chess, but it seems to me especially in
ahead of the Grand Prix
and again remember the tie-break that you
Shahriyar Mamedyarov commented, you know
I think it's worth thinking about it
do some work with a psychologist
that these misfires occur
literally in every tournament he succeeded
win the sims cup feel the but this
there was again a closed tournament, that is, where
at stake, of course, was first place and
victory over magnus carlsen and then
it's in the seventeenth well, as it were
that psychological burden, but in this
sky tournament
what could win lose nothing
the day before you mean by knockout
sometimes it's a hard game he lost in
last year hikaru nakamura do you remember him
levon aronian lost the match o completely
tragic and
did not qualify for the Candidates Tournament
seventeenth year this year by the way in
world cup is no less tragic
lost maximum absolutely won
again, the position of the zina was not there
the question of first place has not yet reached
finals, well, look at all the finals of maxims
he lost almost everything
it seems to me and I'm actually very
I'm rooting for Maxim in this match since I already
you could be suspected of me
forced to tell about who and who
who will win these between coulson and this
gram yes well that is so that you don't
doubted to confront this
the studio goes on because I'm the one
longtime fans on the same no
no secrets in this ain't there
behavior continues to disagree but
corner here what is there to disagree
agree blond plays harder
brunette before or somehow will but on
in fact, I think it's just not
does not want what sounded in this studio in
Marseillaise hangs on it for a long time I'm ready
to ready to in this studio
sounded the Marseillaise after
brilliant victory din lies rook 8
meanwhile played and no matter how it was
you know the signal to the baby 8 to no then
there are whites almost obliged to go
rook one seems to me because in
otherwise black here may
start pestering somehow rook 4 already
rook one will not be due to the fact that on c4
hanging pawn then black on occasion with
two tacs line i.e. white to some
sense
probably forced to move rook 1 but
then what does dean mean does he mean
in view of that there is some to it
attempt at overplay
or will quietly change but also
actually aline change black not
must change black and be fruitful 8
play she and here is another question of move c5
no by chance probably no just
they took away something that was not a summer rebound
descendant
so wait, how did they take it away
or taken as an elephant because there is
option to pick up the bishop and play
owners 8 and maybe it's like
strange more precisely because c5 dc are white
can play knight d2 and threatens
put the knight on c4 after which it is unlikely
Black is better despite the extra pawn
before the elephant will be very dumb
although in general it's hard to say
say but probably white
refrain from c5 just walk here I am
one such will be the verdict what on
lade one means dinul hedgehogs
well, let's say black tries
play to win on maybe lag f8
now that is how we would get rid of
from the c5 threat and try to get 5 of them
fall on f2, maybe something
such and then I don't care you don't
you'll come again after getting along alone what's here
I'll go created
1 of 5 I can even take on f5 chains
take with the rook c5 well, yes, probably all this
leads to some kind of simplification and does not look like
really doesn't look like black
any chance of winning
Evgeny Vitalievich Elmira is trying
Fedorovna answer the question because
we have here welcomes about how question
I don't remember which for a played on
wheels habu all gays what was the result
and what for and gave mit den to you you
know if you're talking about that session in
which we participated together with maxim
and they chamberry
we played with
with moriuchi in this session we were given
handicap in two figures, again, this
standard fora
such great chess players all the Gestapo
I was offered work by two figures and a maxim
they lost something to their opponent
managed to checkmate but I really
I don't understand at all how
carried out some combination there and even
Moriuchi san praised me but I think
my show is over
shocker tournaments by tags and
when maxim
and when we went to japan with maxim
a little later, maxim brace and moriuchi
played chess he had already played two games
and participated in the World Championship
chess compositions are more so light
Palte they played all the gi among themselves
of course for and given as always
advanced there are two chess pieces
some truck maxim pretty no i
just not a very strong chess player
curious yes that is what would be
adequate for a
fury in two figures all gi
you know, it seems to me that the session went on
with the clock went with the clock this is for this
how to be a strong chess player
maybe that's not enough
insufficiently equalized the ratios, as it were
I sat down well, well, imagine that's it
I understand that you are playing in yourself
level of some average amateur
suppose yes that is you don't
professional on the axis you offer you
offer a quarrel in two figures that's how
what handicap should a chess grandmaster
giving mean lovers to it here
still had an interest here clearly not
two figures it seems to me and 1 then the figure is not
of course because all gi after all
party develops initially very
slowly and
it's hard for me even it's hard at once yes it's hard
compares because in chess
bandage on figure can be
can be used literally immediately
slowly use the preponderance's break
one figure to even get
more comfortable to drive
the fact that in grrange the story was very
looked good if me here
allowed all the participants would give me
head start horse yes boogie fisher from one
a woman will give odds with a figure anyway
win, I'm not sure
keshechka rf could he give in our
time
such a strong chess player as for example
she we why you win Zhenya the ashes of uefa not me
already generally silent depends on the pawn then
means communication is sure that blacks
best loved them no pawns from the basques
Yes, I’m just not sure that I killed them better then
that black is better in general with
you can try to play with the computer
Yes, listen, but here we really are
while we were talking about other games
rook 1 and not repeating fritter beta 1
candy 1 and at the moment when white's knight
is located on the edge of the board, apparently in the very
terrible on the most terrible bullet yes that is
black moves first from 6 to 7 aiming
to Fergie 4 and if actually worthy
the answer is what has been for three
I suspect I'm not really
I understand how scary it is
Even three hangs up to need to defend a pawn
same 3, let's say the queen move is somehow d3a
maybe b3 steam queen will help here
it saves and translate the freesia meeting
yes because let's say queen b3 is black
answers the same 5 and by the way it can already
ends badly
same 5 gh4
but there is a move to the queen h3 there is a move
queen b3 attacking bishop after sun 5
queen f3 and it looks like white has time
play fergie in time and it's easy
drag to them already five there is still
for 300r firs and that's what happened queen
b3
bishop c5 queen f3 but here is the outcome 5
some who until the end all the same to me
still can't figure out how
judged because ours is black
scratching 4 on fiji 2 beat on the same 3 queens
And
[music]
here he is not only in an interesting sense
interesting mostly black in this
position option is interesting mainly
black, that is, maybe some
there really are problems after ferris
before 7 there's some move freddy 2 scott
move queens 2 which does not let yet
queens aka 40 black you have a choice
wanted to say either queen 4 knight now
no need 3 1 2 goes and somehow try
here to play and the second oddly enough
it's even possible now
consider i.e. fergie 4 buy
white
apparently they are obliged and more or less not
places same 3 have someone move korolev one
yes then it is not enough well let's say
here is korolev 1 of 5 yes here is how to it
treat just a couple of me kinda like
stock big keep ties yes i
I agree, black still wants
save friends so most likely on
queens 2 some movie for 4
planned in general curious what
maxim just feels clearly worse
white, that is, the whole question is how much
worse, yes, that is, not just shadows
even White did not get an advantage, but even so
fall into a relatively nasty stance
and the Aronians have Oscar Svan there too
followed by a few moves there pretty
curiously it looks like a change is coming
frenzied structures offer blow or
will end switch and in the meantime I'm so
will understand that the questions are in the chat, which is joyful
something that has changed even link broadcasting before
was announced 1 let's go a little bit
under under another under another link and
I'm glad that they still found and look at us
wait a minute we've seen my water videos and
2 on how he is IS-7 during ramming after
queen h5 answers knight g6 this is interesting
that is, to take on the same 6 you have to beat
the same
but apparently again immediately either or or how
blacks should play it
here is the question
because so long term that
is called, of course, the pawn on e6 is weak and
some could potentially be
black problems can be elephants 4 all
try to change the elephants first
yes then you are somewhere tip
this is where c5 is, you know, you know there
on and 6 here the problem is what after
this move white beat on and in 4 did not take
went to 4 to play with the pace yes that is
here
as if in four rings 5 ​​can be
well, that is, either you need to change to the same 5 and
go into defense yes well then kodak
broke very much I think very satisfied
and the horse up to 3 is given there as a lead
and 1 to 4 goodness would not like with black
what i wanted couture we would not like
to stabilize the position before after
after a potential exchange she is 6 s
on the other hand because magnus thinks
I would venture to guess what he sees
then there may not be a chance
rush to beat us something played magnus
slot up to 32 but like this to put it mildly
mysterious
I will assume that here is the case of conditional e5
retreats beforehand as a bishop until after 5
to say take on and five days after
baths five days of fun
the bishop did not hang on d3 on the other side, but
there yes you see the option lean on d3 on
e5 knights 5 rooks one black could beat
on Petra
say yes section some move king
h1 same three king steps proud yes let
e5 hole not tying 51 but there is a move
country there rook on f8 you are protected
put with rooks 8 just take on e1
aslan leaned c2 already this bunch
unpleasant say 5 is not not very
I'm sure that I Peter wants me
it seems black is not necessary
readjust now the king of the living
you can play
it is not clear whether the king's move was necessary at all
h8 but now she definitely can
there king h8 for something to free
cage for a horse
perry king same 8 maybe to you
now be able to beat as well on
bishop g6 yes, and black outlines a conditional
there, as if at 4, you still want somehow
slightly replace this whole economy
true here yes here again coming back
skoda already twice three
I like this position again
limit the knight
6 so that he doesn’t jump anywhere like that
carnage 88 game can you imagine how much
unusual all the same for playing this
position if necessary each time
adapt screams warming white
do almost the only move that
do not immediately weaken the position
I wonder how the computer raises such
position does he understand anything at all
these structures the computer is better than all of us
I think he understands and would not really like
at the canyon to carry out the plan that's it
I'm 3 by 4.
yes, it’s understandable, but the care is already three all the same and
begging somewhere for either taking
either there on f5 it has risen in price by 4 times to that
same hoja 3 like it
still as an option maybe even 3 of 4
back off 5 sooner or later you will have to
there seems to be nothing for elephants to do
same 5 that is, first let's go same 3 to
prevent
elephants 4 xo although the course is like
impression here immediately and still walks
but here and here's what we talked about that is
don't give now take on the same 64 to
more precisely, you can take 1 6 but in order to have
possibility
Ambassador same 6 be a wife now we
examined now suppose same 3
z3
and how to react to the same 3 yes not easy
not easy
especially the outline of Black's game is not
you can see really if not all the same not
be taken seriously and 5 maybe
you can and if q10 end is-7 and beyond
where
but suppose we discussed with you
move h4 let's say white floor 4
wanted to play this strange position
slope again if perturbed at 5f y
I will then be able to play
four no don't think just don't get up
most likely it can be dressed up empty
owned and 1
and here I don’t even want three new k
the word in some no is served by figure 5 i
still wanted to be bound by haste and
cool 5 hanging while free on white
white mouths concentrated pieces
giving black it is not clear what to do before
ending tip to you already yes well that is
you get two pawns for a piece in a new way
the feeling of this is also not enough elephant d2
retreating Magnus then remembered something like
elephant d2 we also sounded up to withdraw
Bishop g5 though, I don't really like it here
it is clear that on the difficult in 4 is it really on and
one will retreat, which is basically wrong
pointless retreat on and one somewhere
play like I mentioned 3 of 4
maybe even stabilize prices
they will give Magnus Kasha a virtuoso of such positions
given words 4 i really like the idea
layer
play with the moon and one yes and if black
tries e5 at this moment until the piece
very well located pagoda
hooked up on 6
means that I like it even after
how black spends e5 we have
a very good f5-square for both the queen and
can you go to the elephant
those. as if with swords, well, they take something
he sings to her until the elephant is up to 2
I'll be surprised if this works
generally go to the endgame is just conditional
one pretty stuck what is all the same
white changes let's fill college and 5
now even gave 11 than
there, finally, a4 is rather unpleasant
the king is two years four now on b2
attacked again so as not to go to
some sizes almost boat 2
have to walk it's not probably not
very lucky to be caron same 2 slowly
maybe you can in this position
try to knock out the elephant and play 4
now the icon is 3, although it is still multi-colored
not guaranteed absolutely equality
yes, because so far it’s like 6 games are not
maybe the whites will have time for something there
attack and if after f4 play cavalry
4 but here again here at the expense
off the elephant 6 can try to
some specific options but let's say
jump to c5 start or change these
the queen's pawns may be in time for white
a little earlier means to tell me what
computer liked our offer
same 3g 3 play yes yes care more or less
standard same do now
black it's not so easy all the same game with
such a position is again a boor against
magnus
how hard is he why did the water go ah
and 8 rascals his family still hasn't
I can of course what can be some
the illusion was to support at 5
worked without very clearly responded well
here's another question and friends to play
I accepted that you are such a strange move
least and yet elmira
question of evgeny you said that soon
will you be in Moscow please tell me how
I can take a photo with you
know i think evgeniy will be very happy he
will appear at the World Blitz Championship and
parapet well to all fans
and a fan advise hostages or you
you will comment from but come on
support the intrigue and well, it seems, it seems,
really seems to be in the puddles
commentary
box studio yes therefore yes if so
there really is such a desire
meet chat date come and
tournament actually look like
I think it will be interesting
a perfectly reasonable position proposal if
yeah if we don't fall apart right away before
after the lean rush something offer
reasonably drove to them 5 to try
still a horse in 4 they play like 4
force whites to change something
at least a couple of figures yes I don’t really understand
how do we react transmitted geoeye-1 what
e6 again
begins to freeze analogies one can
to be we are an elephant and at 4 we go did not expect
say
based on the idea of ​​what to take on e6
it's impossible because of the rains so first here
warm up and then we’ll pick up 2 and on
knight 2 is knight 4 and win
black win material say
they probably win, but that’s quite what
everything turned out badly for all white people
be them but also in 5 so let's say
responsible from of course yes further not
you can already actually like minced meat is impossible
says to crank the meat grinders back
income after leaving 5 back f5 to all
unfortunately it won't be right
weakly rush and 6 to the end of the park now
guaranteed on the other hand otherwise
responsive data drag or 3g
3g you can try but then already
probably in all serious yes there and in 4
somehow justify the presence of Laden
f8 and so on can be white here
here again, not fully sharpened under
such a super sharp game but royal
what is 4 3 well, that is, it is not clear what
this time read serve part as well
fiji 6 take aka traila keeps two
some kind of position
Thomson 6 and then the rains come, that is
take here
Well, I guess you should start with
some intermediate care owns
six approaches to the seller have to put
41 I decided everything for myself that having dressed
impossible already forgot why therefore yes
that is, in fact, at 4 you just
it turns out you hit but the same chance twice and food
I don't really like this position
took but maybe serves 3 still not
rushing is very disgusting that's the fact
recognize the login and 80 because here
except for ageev 6 the second move which I
like owns 3 he's here again
yawn rook and you date well on while on
service g3 you got out even two can
again, you can’t play 4 and screens at 4
and black has nothing to beat at 4 or mate on the same
everyone to receive either yawns the rook then how
what is he holding
base sonar nasty yes that is maybe
to be here and on f6
but even here it's like 6 like in 6
rook 11 can im get off probably
get black to everyone until wild debuts
at 6 no if you look and there is something
some kind of tactic I'm not in the camp
count up to her no care well it looks like
here owns 6 werder 6 yes some
no you want to say i think i
already ran
let's go that she move the queen to everyone if
fall back on the same 4 and now says that
have tactical dressed aka 7 or immediately
elephant jesse to me but this one looks
critical for what servant g7 is like
enmity to the g7 service is now impossible to be a bishop
take an offer g7 i retreat somewhere
somewhere here it really seemed to me that
this position is unpleasant probably that is
accordingly, this is not so, I'm not somewhere
switched there, let's all go back
still position Korsuna sara not and us after
so wait there's something going on
king 8 bishop d2 move which
we missed you and which is possible
and magnus missed
dropped at least kanebo 4 would send one
fall back to them back on ceshin try
before trying to indicate what you don’t have here
no good, settle for a draw cats
so trying to convince the wounded magnus we
we are still waiting for victory in the classical
fingers and at least someone
please yes not that we had
some clear favorites given let me remind you that
this is the second final such final
Tournament Edge is often glad before that just
by points scored here in the preliminary
stages the winner was determined here with
last since last year since last series
decided to hold the final tournament and in
last year the final tournament is not in
semi-finals not in the match for third place
then and the final was not played a single
scoring game in classic all
solved in rapid chess and blitz
and last year's winner
hikaru nakamura series he is in general for the whole
the series is gone and the party in the classics is not you games
curious .
I'm just trying to justify the cheat
party and fast [ __ ] because i
it seems that again if all the severity
wrestling and especially
transferred to fast and on and on [ __ ]
when it should be calculated and tai
break then you just need to get rid of
no, well, okay, another format
tournament yes can be invented
organizers, but if it's a victory
absolutely deservedly obtained in
fast
in a blitz of this they must be shortchanged maybe
be yes, well, and that's how much it is already clear that
get rid of the classics it's so it
such an ironic comment
I do not urge you to do this, but here's something
I definitely need to change it seems to me
just in such options when
only two classical parts and very
big let's say a big difference
between defeat and draw and so what
everyone is trying to play on defense don't let
god lose in class what are my chances
win back yes with minimal risk yes yes
that is, people are trying to play
minimal risk and here I am already
voiced repeatedly and actually not
I remember there are some about this
rational objections but I don't remember them
so I'll say it again, it seems to me very
good idea to play a tie-break all the way
boy thats a famous famous idea yeah
to make it clear man
the losing tiebreaker must win
match in the classics otherwise he
with a draw, so to speak, he already shored there
lost on the one hand it to the audience
guarantees action yes i.e. is played and
fast and blitz there da bucks armageddon s
the other side
removed here is the lottery yes what are we
played two games in a draw in classical two
party draw there in rapida blitz and then
in one batch without adding 5 to 4
suddenly decide the fate of the match
it's very ordinary you seem to me she
spoke about my
the world championship is just a match, yes, that's
when first Magnus Karjakin where was
two productive games here at the hobby with
Magnus and not 1 at all, despite the fact that their
cannot be blamed
Let's just say in the absence of an Ostia militant
the parties were saturated and yes it is
interesting
to a narrow circle of professionals, yes, that's who
just does not look at the desk online inspection
then the results see that
grandmasters played there for three weeks
collected all twelve games in a draw
and then to the word here is such a question that
we are thinking about the proposal
vladimir kramnik to cancel
castling i again
already said a little sentence
vladimir kramnik
and even looked through the games played
computer really they are very
interesting there arises
crazy fight here while keeping on
wing in the center how the computer solves these
problems what positions seeks
indeed the parties were very
interesting what do you think so on
at first glance, yes, these are the parties that
published and not interesting until disappears
chess disappears for a while
theory but does it make chess richer me
not sure far because but think
whole cluster positions disappear someday
position with opposite castling my
most likely official
the squares f1 f8 will become a refuge for the king yes
because still imagine escaping
king on the queenside on foot much
opening theory changes less often here yes
for a while it will be understood what will happen
looking for new directions we'll get rid of
post in the theory that have grown well the whole i
I don't fully understand how this will affect
it seems to me again
just think about what we
strive yes if add entertainment to
tournament, well then you can add a move and
a couple of figures and make out already pick up a pair
pieces if you still save chess
appetite chess harmony harmoniously and
arrangement of figures we return to
Fischer's chess that sometimes there is a position
obtained after the draw is very
unfortunate them they are not so easy to play
I think it's worth thinking about
changing the actual format then
maybe come up with something like this
control and time is really someone
tournament format in which it would be
more reasons to take from grandmasters
risk on yourself so on and so on yes but
look Magnus doesn't repeat where he goes
Bishop would be one d3
I renounce my previous
statements that like c2 is better than on
d3 is located now feeling black
it seems like they can consider the move and ping
yes i changed the position he stands on
d2 suppose that here come on wait on
going somewhere after the tip suppose that
white immediately went bishop to 2 black
black play king g8 and move again
black that's what happened yes so
it turns out that I can played slate for
bishop on d2 retreats perricone b4 bishop
one knight c6
and black spent two moves went to b4
back to 6 and white bella full of bishops
three moves
well, I won't give you the opportunity
that's exactly how it pisses you off
ingeniously
how much is ingenious really is me
seems to be some kind of cross marking time
so intricate no seriously i'm not really
I understand, that is, on the other hand, maybe
black doesn't really want f5 even in this one and 5
5 even in this situation yes be black
don't really want e5 here come on again
think out well and here's some move
olya ladya and him
and I'm alone yes they are 44 I'm not sure how much
you want because they will take me again
the game on d5 cannot be immediately taken on d3
because connected pawn eating a concept
as it is m still go still and second
I will devour it insolently, yes, that is, here it is
it's not very clear can i and chili
Asia 4 Can't Then It All Feels
hang horses again as it seemed to me
I also managed to calculate something like
it would be impossible to take more from whites there and on
e5 yes because you [ __ ] and are tied
still
mate on h7 threatens so there is no escape
the owner of e5 needs to retreat with White's bishop
clear advantage
that is, there may be such an objection
on and 5 that white just let down the second
got along and then they probably threaten how it is
let's play events let's give after the move
yes, you wait with her after the move first d7
played max played 1 a max
played the same 2 same 3 here is the move that we
discussed what is there through h3 everything is possible
one immediately moves the same 5 to 5 here
Maxim just raised his hand to take Auger
and then abandoned 3 edited by me
I'm trying to understand what's going on
pretty curious
swindler first d1 I'm not there for the taking
so wait you don't want to drink knives 5
no, I want to, that is, they took up to us as many as three
first and didn't want the day, but then the queen h3
griefer g46 college not or can just
landscape 3 to deshty no but need a pawn the same
to defend we looked with you at the move here
queen b3
maybe there's something out for a penny to be
it could be this transition to be honest
here is the previous line
maybe then some kind of transition
previous lines which are for white
looked very dangerous shales 5 what
now do i.e. move queen f3
chernukha floor 4 and that's it with the queen on
b3 I have the opportunity to take
frying the entrances
if you forget and queen b3 come back i
know how to react a peasant woman 6 to
black yes literally no matter how funny it is
a certain position tsups wang what you scored
now make them move either the queen
from under protection removed to either
well then there are no other moves therefore
from black strings move king same 6 go
they already threaten as much as four feet shorter than 6
now you have the code queen f3 garden
check on f6 maybe not so stupid
it looks like white is holding on to some
there already on its last legs, well, maybe
it can't be all that weird
equals 4 crave
there are three not every training against 1 3 4
pawn on and 4 minutes what black shure
but the advantage cannot be otherwise with
horse for one yes that is not possible
on another with a horse on one down to
the fact that you can survive four
return in this position attack e4
knives 5 still on the same 3 somewhere
the threat still hangs h5 h4
unpleasant position maximum 100
spearmen even I'm losing sight of
in almost every calculation one of them
this stake on one of course very much and
very very very awkwardly located and
looks like it won't be anytime soon
and you want more about this come on come on
back again 5g queen h3
walking sense would consider option
queen b3 sun . tomorrow
having approved 34 yes and here I am not really
I understand how to continue to
fiji 2 have hotfix exchange 3 and this
wrong where the leg sense to change
here or some horse to play against
elephant yes right there the problem is what what if
now it's just impossible to play yak-3
yes at the other end of the zone in 2
elephants 2 are taken away so it feels
all the same, she will have to change the queens
let's try to play this
king same 2 before black something take away on
f2 suppose so pawn to start
almost not absolutely hopeless f2 we don't
take away never black go king on
same 6 take our 5 even that's what
absolutely hopeless rain when I
like queen move 3 let's wait
same queen strokes with b3 sun 5 right here
if you go with us
and here
besides this, your brilliant ideas to give
check and go back maybe on your
family back then fergie 4 and also not
very clear as after g4 as the first
up to 3 is possible while i have to let our 4 walk
king 2 yes, that is, it's all wrong
too sad h3 looks nasty soft
speaking
but maybe yes maybe and here
somehow here and we need to hold on
Well, Maxim has almost taken on the same 5 but
apparently as a cult from
he sees an alternative to take from us again
because I thought again and probably
even though we missed
quite a lot of his first moves
probably still one break here
today let's take a break for a while
both parties have a slightly different character
but this is clearly defining
now the stage yes, maxim needs exactly
easy to find
if protection exists, then look for it
need right now
and the Aronians have such an unpleasant omission
positions he urgently needs to organize
kuta counterplay
[music]
beat off, I choose a mile, but I don’t burge
similar
and the heavens above us and I and the pit won't get better
dylan de landa landing i im tagging violently
your ayman dad puran ebu
about him in a certain way I'm going and
[music]
tosato we have a hatch for the sake of finishing this time
on video by icon
the road of his ability times his
valentine sucked since banana
rewind the sharpness of sanitation
[music]
and warriors brik pineapples and no war I'm on
it’s clear to yourself that I appeared there
beloved to Peter
[music]
she is in memory of the 20th century from the rank and here
critters nadia it and you act on the bank
on the device you have to go on the toe on the egg she
running around
arafa people doing it was so hard bass
line is five
little me on my lessons in soft with pipa
but alas medline samples big ass back on
the girls i flew to the house may take the
people on this place of a domain name is
hot dog brought in by their
simple you mantoux edius online mastered
arina and himself money or mohican warrior
stone and sand and got out how important is
interested
you again less than the remote control soma bay goats
a smallville kolka stuff at school a bandage or
alder match second he will report and
prosupport milf lisa and that's uganda lives
of the by april 1 day to the core and pass
you
[music]
fomina plastic
be a fireplace joy-cons or sciences
Britney Trace Van Gypsum and Mog Barns and
kulagin fades better not seeing a them his
green door to
put on dag get from these mens and in
samara because of green 2tb
and again this year record the night you yourself
work hard
which mirena from dark is not a movie at the car before
simplistic synagogue photofast amelie
because the intention
I
nice
operator
here is the regulator to approach me
[music]
[applause]
it's fault beautifully written maracaibo
soul changes naginata when a guy
streets on it could i face i'm like that
[music]
and letter often site legend
its let's make the leaves kids pelle
it is him and here is caseing
terms and world lights now fund and
synthesis of advice on the help
[applause]
[music]
here
so friends back to the air
I remind you today is the first day of the final
the final stage of the final tournament
grand hour tour played 1 classic
game and the actual final match for
break time so not one move is made and
was not but a certain development of events
happened in the game of Carson and Aronian
I remember this match for third place no matter how
strange as strange as it may sound before
to see magnus not fighting for victory in
the tournament as a whole is unusual
guilty lost
semi-final match so I suggest yes
let's look at this game a little
and we will return when to the final when already
Maxim still makes a move, while Magus
we saw as far as I remember the move bishop b1
on d3 back discussed all the same who
lost to those who won the pace and
the general recommendation was the same as before
Well, it's time to finally organize where
contour game on another wounded played water
and 8 b8 and after bishop e3 was played
rook f8 e.v.
different but it is not visible and also more precisely in
Lebanese probably ask why
preferred to play ladies she and 8 a
now I've decided to rebuild, well, go
rooks b8 hints at a potential idea
bassem b6 and either 75 which is most likely
the same thing because I seem white
take on b6 and bishop 3 of course with and
protect the pawn on b2 and
to support the Canadians, yes, that is, apparently in
case fate 6 can be sure 6
consider we suppose took took
yes and cavalry 5 somehow in this way
White would continue the game in this case
ambassador deev and 8 same 2 same 3 plays magnus
carlsson
preventing possible jumps in
four black figures in general yes it looks like
that the lemon has an uncomfortable situation
there is gradually he starts like this and by
time to lag behind already soon 15 minutes
the difference will be on the clock and indeed
clearly it’s not visible the plan of the canter game
yes, and the movement of the pawn b is connected rather
creation of new
weaknesses than with some real outline
game and 5 never materialized about
White still has a lot of moves which position here
so feel better give king barely
does not look superfluous and can be
really move pawn h
now when the rook, therefore, was already going like
leaving all of us in 5 speech is not particularly
feeling of course the world champion is very
comfortable situation, what will we
offer for black here again
to consider the move e5 to lebanon right here
it makes no sense, well, let's try the 6th
5 how to react where and 4 can be in
we are not very afraid of this version, yes, I am
I wanted to say what after yes and how
then after so she has 5 somehow with whites
once again you have to move the elephant
yes, most likely 103 where it can be on
f5 put it like black cavalry 4
probably not so bad everyone starts more often
there is such an oppositional idea in
such positions that they accepted to put forward
nadia kuni because uncle's body where i am not
I know how it is possible then quietly and
dummy for 2 5 will be lost immediately if
they serve there, they lost d3o grandfathers 3
hanging on foot running horses 5 you know
unleashed of course 6 and now I
not at all sure you need debit letters
again I'm not sure about Fritz 4 should be 6
the elephant weighs but although it may be through c4
trouble lags 6 same 7 same 6 fine-tuning such
attempt
play tactics there hangs a rook
on barely maybe maybe start
right away 6 can be start right away 6
exactly 6 retreat must always lose
a little harmony, so there would be no
I would like it if black moves and 5
I don't want to kill
I would like the end of a6 to activate then
there can again do some
deep moves elephant up to 32 notes
Aronian just moves knight 8 instead of moving
there are 6 and 5 retreats to them substantially
f8, that is, apparently, 7, but 6 after all
will play and then lead the horse to dc here
such a feeling, that is, this horse is already
the poor community would have been visited just
in all fields, yes, I just tried
wondered what the trajectory was
trajectory but back on the same 8 on there
multiple f8 so
I'm quite right don't you think
you don't want to be defined as a7 off
I again so weakens the pawn
d5 well, well, what should White do after
knight f8 may be in anticipation of x even 6
6 I think I'll have to sooner or later
play can be play h4 no matter how
it's strange to say the same case 6
retreat and is ready to kill move h4 and h5
this is quite unpleasant for blacks
there must be a movement of the pawn h
another question is what after h4 probably
win all the same all f5
villains 4 play yes maybe that's how
strangely, we don’t hold the horse like this
having eaten she f8 we move the f-pawn so that she
move on to this country in this
position appears
also interesting 4 now let's say in
this particular position probably kanebo 4
not very pleasant but in general 24 so that
dc elephant c4 will almost always be bad
because of the pawn on and 6 is weak yes probably
it makes sense too
while we look at magnus and such a question
can he get to 2900 on
it seems in another tournament they answered
similar question and I thought
came to the ice because Magnus still
still did not realize its potential
creatively especially on the last
the results on the map I perhaps but at the same
time is still needed except for some
colossal stability which
there is definitely a need for another series
good results apparently to catch
because well, he climbed
the maximum is 882 on a sheet
was and 886 was current but with such
difference in rating with even these
super elite chess players account for
almost plus 5 to dial in each
tournament, but it's still difficult and any
let's say the result + 3 on average
gives in a wiki circle of this level a division of 1
that is, the first place is clean, well, here in
worst case division first place for
can this mean a loss of 10 points
ranking is hard to imagine therefore
here you can look in two ways, either
the middle fields will pull up so to speak yes
a few more people to take 2 800
then it might be easier
to carry out well, or you really need to
some kind of catch such a passing
wind catch and a few oh yes oh
some fantastic results
we saw it at the beginning of this year, yes there
here in the month of April when two in a row
tournament in my opinion in this vein Magnus
won the toast classic yes that's it
germany and memorial in gashimov mountain
when the tour to the end was already celebrated
with a victory in the last round he also won
just in case, that is, maybe here
such is the recipe to dial 2,900 a 2,900 y
it seems to me that he was in the blitz rating
I guess, that
reaching the milestone
places how would we get to magnus in
tournaments matter again you don't don't
you underestimate that
justice and strength
statistics, yes, with such a difference in
ranking
magnus would have to dial
approximately 50 out of 50 are guaranteed
that you won’t do a draw for me, for example, in
one game with white
white color can be made from
five out of 50 maybe a couple of draws
respectively future lose let
there is played wounded still again we
talked about it so much is given
vitamin fitness time
why does he play so long
tense parties sometimes literally on
out of the blue even the greatest chess players
they are wrong because but not
the brain can already withstand such a load
that's why
maybe he can do it somewhere
add our either with time
again, well, that is, the option with 2 900 is not
excluded here is the verdict of the court
so in the meantime we have what's going on while we
change your mind, maxim didn’t take a photo
then Maxim still thinks let's
back to the same final game
where is the maxim of your graph with white pieces
seems to be in a pretty awkward situation
vs dean lying on finals
maxim something does not add up yes that's it
here already he thinks about half an hour before we
switching parties entered Lavrov and
don't eat denali after the last move
which was made g6 same 5 what move
quite aggressive yes I'm like us
succeeded in finding out cases of the same should
landscape 3 threatening pawns same 3 on defense
when we continue a little with our
how they looked at frisbee 3 and the sun
534 I wanted to see our horse
us here if anyone is less likely to end 5
there settle down element it's a draw that's it
but it may be that we forget
I don’t know all the transitions in writing, that is
in fact, the calculation goes like this
understood everything is calculated write on your
later he beats c5 and now apparently shox h2
and take and on f2 first date of 2
what it is
here it doesn't look like there are any
problems before change in 2 yes yes price and
just approached the position on the map with
the shorter the three reach to so too
you can walk in what is covered 40 h4 published
here it’s as if black questions didn’t start
ask yes but also doesn't seem like yes that is
actually
seo
queen d2 move which we actually
somehow they didn’t consider it at all, but come on
well it's the same 5 and queen and c2d 2
attacking the same pawn 5 verse about something good
I guess it's yes
how black should even walk around here
wait maxim thought give me 40 minutes
think
2 minutes how black should move from and
position
and the transition to such a spire is already saving everything
pawns somehow g-4 g-5 also to the records
shorter than 6 she is unfortunate then what to me she is without
rush stay even the king same 2 and 4
well, that is, let him call back and on
actually there at the moment when the white knives
5 hit they have a knight in the corner
convey maybe it somehow
use
king f8 can't believe george course
calmly on the queen e5 apparently korolev 8
there horses are lost or something after a personal
Shah most likely will not and cannot
get lost look guys h4 like
queen 4 win yes because no
there is no perpetual check if it's one
is lost just checks yes therefore
I guess it's planned first beats
h5 here now some checks
appear two in a row and this name is what
the king will leave sooner or later dacha through
let's say through king e-8 queen as much as 8
king d 7a no king up 7 series h3
queen f1 but maybe the king can't
the king can’t even leave here until 85 is
not by the rules shahboz quite possible
move as we know from the game before
sees but wait a minute numbers on
stop, unfortunately I knocked everyone down
confused because queen f1 has income but
he does not save the knight with an empty d4 and still
the horse is caught well what to do then
may be
black has a good position
come stop like this
there is no foolish tactic here to play c5
black beats the bishop apparently and what
play knights b3
again creating a threat on and now on
retreat but suppose due to black
fully cooperates there goes like that
word b6 then already start giving there
check and pick up you must not leave
kubica 5 is not here rather here is some
move fergie 4 try to play queen
yes horse
c5 bc black for now just in case 2
superfluous and perpetual check is not visible yes no
the problems are still the same
problems and it can not be that maxim here
really
missed that long line
which we discussed a year later h5 and even
was it like that no yes queen
queen 484 stroke prize lifan yes so 1
here, yes, that is, the shah king must come here
shahnoz 3 king goes to c7 but also behold
here you can’t see the checker’s horse for one
lost yes it looks like black just
win again on firm f1
bishop d4 yes but I felt something
something else needs to be done but completely
not the fact that it saves c5 black for the sake of
there is no reason not to capture on c5 with the bishop yes a
wait, now you can go to this
option to give check and take on h5 by
at least in the version that we
Treated Before Will Shah Shah Sasha 4
king d7 suppose you're black
go by the same option now as
only the role goes to line c queen
fadin and scrapped to 4 have step 1 and rings
two three i can go king white king
gone yes and now if one more step up
then system shock I don't know
Yes, I didn’t get it, I somehow wanted it already through
king again
but
strange a little of course opinion will be
never about really c5 sun
5 cafe g5 step by intuition still should
be the way to win for black but
tuition intuition let's see what
in reality it will happen in a year h4
Maxim plays and everything is very simple on
queen 4 chance up to 8 and check 5 perpetual check
well, that is, white is still without a pawn to a pawn
it can be saved by saying and playing the sphere
g4 but how won is th besides
the horse comes out yes there is another question
otherwise it looks like the pawn h5 will not protect
well, maybe a good resource was found
the terrace might not be worth defending
eco group
how if you want kunic morning
nucleophilic 6 after examining
personal saffron
but i give shahinshah
now you can go but it is nevertheless something
it leads to something like this
here
ending with a bishop against a knight yes probably
and this is an improved version because
that here blacks take her at 5 to play
on the next move up to be taken away by the king
knives 6 than the course of the game and yelled to pull up
king up the chances of winning anyway
huge they have here when standing
consider them h5 but there it will be lost
horse after although 235 but flexible here
queen the first and even on f2 God forbid
it’s bad for everyone, it’s hard, it looks like he killed them
it's hard, of course it will be such a blow
from which it will be very difficult to recover
Let me remind you that it's not here
not only in the classics the match is decided, but then
there is this is not the system we are used to
like in the world cups what if you won the match
in the classical stage, then the rest
parties are not played will still be
play both rapid and blitz maximum will be
a chance to recoup even if he doesn't win
second before after losing at 1
classical but a difference of six points for
one batch is of course a serious backlog
try your best to save
trying to save is not particularly visible when not
it is especially clear how it will also have to be sooner
just to protect some
in a hurry, I completely understand sergey life
the only move of the spectrum is not very good for me
even there will be care king e-8 for example
we really then probably just he would
three plays prezi have more like
good good and if we say the move is king
the same 2 is done so far it seems not anyway
you threaten with nothing and here the queen is here
king 8
still with the threat due to the double at 23
then the horse stands by us drag the cavalry 2
but if there is no mine puppeteer 2 everything
is there any there or heart 4 or
these four for barely then two
wins curious how the cards are there and
mira explained that in the opening White
the task is to gain the advantage of the knight over
dark-squared elephant us here in my opinion with
it is contrary to prove exactly the opposite
on the contrary, we are again not like blacks
upsets but something white to the end
one should be on d5 that's it
white did wrong in this game before
imagine that the knight is on d5 and then I
I think that the lack of a pawn is not particularly
worries white is in perfect order
be what am i mage us what is magnus well
let's see what magnus has here
till
the finale is still up part now
any think denly don't have time yet
let's have enough chess players
switch to the mongoose party there too
what events did it happen anyway
moved a pawn at some point
endured continued curious magus
continued to stomp on the spot
after knights 8 bishop c2 once again
plays now no longer tugan b4 will get
defended and now b6 took took and the elephant
one absolutely relaxed comrade like
Magnus plays that what move has already been
31 moves were made on the board, he again
figures stand very harmoniously, not a single one
elephant's weakness
now he will certainly try
use off moisture weakness or black
cover 6
looks delicious as i think
yes, you need to get pawns a6 not very well
understandable, I think that's the end of 5 just
important now
the important question is whether black will succeed in
to some extent prevent the knight's move
35 let's say 6 play and knight d7 booth
because I honestly don't understand how
back door pass there owning 88
people somehow more or less meaningful
after cavalry 5 kita problems start
yes you can play a6 white again
then continue with this horse
travel horse c3
as a result, they will lead to e5 or to f4 and all
This one
counterplay on the queen's
on the flank, it essentially does not lead to anything
this pawn's only weakness would be 2 to
who oh no way to get the horse on
400 translate in this position but how and but
how yes how not very
clear I like the field too 11
hits the boys 4th it's simple as
it says random move made 88 easy
so that the rook a8 can defend the bridge and
drag
again a4 a3 here is that beauty well
suppose yes well anyway
cavalry 55 seems to me almost here
never we look again yeah well that's all
equal to the horse goes suppose it is necessary three
to collect on e5 anyway
skills problems seen not so obvious
there you need 4 missions and the exchange hangs and yes
even here
combi up to 4 meters train 3 protect on
c1
this is a picture to remember
here in carlsbad
almost 100% of cases
ideal field for a horse in our case
on d3 we need 6 x 1 baht and sausages
rooms
6 it seems to me in lectures
Tigran Vartan still met Petrosyan
published in the Soviet book printing
chess collection of Petrosyan's lectures
there I think for the first time I encountered
the ideas that
the horse must be put on life if you are too
probably yes, that is, it is some kind
counterplay she certainly is he is not
very concrete even if black here
suppose white 6 lost two more
tempo and even black in this position so far
not much threaten to renounce 3
follows b4 again puts the fabric on
c5
well, it's clear that white people won't play anymore
cartridge nuts and g1 back yes that is
these are the most idiotic ones
the moves are still the real outline of the game behind
black is not visible but there are problems
no doubt already been wounded in this
positions are already twice different numbers
watch chess player
aronian and until the end of the game in fact
25 minutes left plus the same one
26 minutes still before plus the same one
delay
30 seconds
what has we to tell the chat i've looked through
a couple of messages at the moment when magnus
pas went elephant c1 maybe i'm like that
one with the transfer of the knight to d3 queens one
candida I don't know how much instead
instead of the sun 1 .
and here is the miss of the last move actually
rings one looks totally believe
it is shorter that it is impossible apparently
pick up attack exit and here come up
question what if 6 start here question
I have to start already 6 on the next
move it can be that's what is available
in view of that is we don't care no where
it seemed to me like this is an illusion of the g6 cover
may be receding at the same 4 but this
deep if it works anyway
is the move slumber g6 in case of water and
2 intermediate there is some step by the elephant
Well, then you need to continue because
that there is one of 5 and maybe black
pieces take on b2 white then on 6 yes
well, that is not so obvious to me
it seems that's why Magnus found yes you can
it can be assumed that
fair remark of the computer but this
yes, it is far from obvious to the human
understanding the income of the sun one quite imagine
understandable because it seems to be a function by
the diagonal control of the elephant performs as
all three so with 1 given and three
some additional functions it has
it seems that we are not alone, he also protects
the b2 pawn is more or less logical
it would seem, well, you know whether it's good or bad
but the rook
and 8 went to b8
this is how Aronian played what we are waiting for
end 5 apparently yes
after probably almost five or
you for home in this position you are in front of
decided to spend not too much yes also not too much
pulling time walks and 5 well here to me
it's completely unclear what it's all about
leads begins some kind of straight line
tactical skirmish yes because
white seems to be able to pick up at 6 is
suspicion that black might fall apart
honestly that is on horseback 6 what
meaning
in order not to lose the material you need to walk
through axes
also yes no here he hangs the whole visit
wrote to grandfather surfer
appears to be more or less the only
move some kind of sacrifice here seat even
no ideas no no own a6 no
it turns out and takfir sasse
white, suppose it rains on e5
wait 2 seconds I thought about this
position means maybe still owning
part I'll tell you there she appears
the same procession of me appears with 6 there still
if I wanted to, of course it's strange
position just play these four
somehow sacrifice the quality of playing this
position
looks honestly enough operas
he 4 for now hangs on d5 i.e. 6
with 3 let's say then e400 of course
scary or adventurous such an idea again
somehow I didn't get here
put everyone to find Fergie 5 there
how much is the game position killed
claws and quality and not particularly visible in what
the problem of gravity is not necessary here it's all here
so I understand that everything is built on
here this tactic yes here m now
can't cubes 8 due to take and one oh i
I do not quite understand what is planned for d
and because taking on 6 white seems to be
can exchange just take on d6 and
water and 2 is protected by the queen until any take
and on e5 the arrival of servant 3
again, the interval is 6, since then in
this moment it prefers before travel
then I can take over and again you
you go and then water 2 weighs and then
I sat and thought I agree I need
back off and f3j now i can take horses
5 and 5s by attacking the queen
let now if you take and she is again an elephant
e5 from moon 3 we will assume for eight of
last strength but there is vodka it's up to 4 on
actually need to count from and the figure
without losing 4 took rook 6 took on 6 to
they even took it to b2, you can take it not here
blacks are in order
it's kinda cannon at 6 of course
critically they are doubtful undoubtedly
continuation otherwise not very
it is clear that there is some kind of
not so not very attractive
but move with knight tempo 4 remove knight sc5
so that he doesn’t hang there then beat him and
I'll be in a very strange position with
an isolated pawn, well, where does it come from
water there on this goes we arrived 5 then
there are whites like getting an insulator yes u
Black has some weaknesses, but if it's on 4
terrible would not want this at all
do I propose to switch
back to the final party there unexpectedly
quite a few moves played in a row and
boards queen with an extra pawn u10 and the same
not
after
here is broken h4 here we are
treated before not played for some
Cause fireside 61 did the king play
and taste and steed role 8 to white on
that played fer law would be three queens than
queen 4 take nc 5 d.c.
after a year h5 freeze e4 and after h8 check
now the king e7 is played and first
scene
I'll drag black's pawn c extra
it is clear that if it fails somehow there
achieve perpetual check then it gradually
slip through during that good chance at
victory must be
by what geometry will they give themselves
logical step what question when how
black moves, that is, for the beginning, bye
the pawn is hanging intact if c4 then this is of course
quite then yes then queen d8 you
probably running away from immediate hiv
ours, although also not so clear Fergie 8
even from immediately forever check is not easy
run away and the second wanted to say that you
let's often in such positions here
gives let's say shox d6 king g7 checks
no more and the whites are returning to the rear
pawn c and black such a dilemma that pawn
yes, it seems like you need to move for this
first must go from the center to through to 4
but I'm starting to attack the eternal again
shah al it's really not quite clear somehow
gradually it seems to me all the same black
let the king down
yes but so they will let the king down to me
seems to be considered
almost
here is the move of ali scammers 4 what was through
protected and attempt first by the king to pass
somewhere in the center, well, yes, that's it
let's say our hit go king e6 on
check from here go somewhere on d5 true
here we rise a pawn
taken away
king c3 and white somehow lead themselves
his pawn, rather, the queen f3 and f4
cheats
in this position
queen f3 first seems to me not very good
well positioned and retreat to d2 and
the races start black with a check
turns here you either need
spend 2 paces to get the c-pawn
stop here before either black
turn into a check, that is, in general, and now
look by the way Ferris up to 4 is just playing
in general, here is some kind of such a design
black ordinary aspire that is they
they are trying to hide their king here
somewhere around here in district 2 in district 1
queen b4 was played and max
walk immediately 4
immediately walks the same 4 now I don't
will pass through now queens six
hearts 5 show office 5 I'm thinking
maybe for 4 while to play
just now even f6 and here somewhere
already tried five f4 f3
yes i also like this idea like on c4
maxim and ask is not yet clear how
reacts moreover still here is the moment
such a square appears on f4 for the queen
king same two simple a to wait
time
king 2 well let's say black
until black understood the difference and then
five maxims plays with model
for 4 5 very quickly for some reason
did the Frenchman count everything?
I don't really understand I don't think so
similar psychological nerves are not given
but
but some desperation I would
described it in such a way that
understands that he needs to create some
counterplay is so desperate a little bit
jerk already 45
what's good how black should right
reacts that he wants maxim 6 4 7 and their
and tation question charged step even
it means that such spiers are worth it
missing so two pawns maybe he
wants to pass, but somewhere on the whole wings 8
the same 65 and there somehow let's bowl maybe
is it or is it all lost
again, for six I'll take me
it seems the king somehow seep into everything
equals the safe zone date for this
the king is just yes, somewhere on d2
he must run away there and there very much more
lucky for black the factor that first
still need 4 protected by a pawn because
that he often what happens are published
some shahida king comes to d5 and
start chasing this king around
queen on here'sa 4 king to 3 series b
one such funny perpetual check
by the way, it could very well be black
that got caught in the perpetual check just wanted
this will really demonstrate
sometimes we even defend without two pawns
side is some kind of
unusual up to a meter and look here
you can king c5 after queen 7 that fact
that the queen on d4 is protected allows
play king b4 think all the same
king running away break hard to stop
from the pass to c1
so it looks like this is the problem
wella what does the center mean yes
well, assuming it's white
skip the movie
dakar g2 example
i.e. how to proceed
what do we say to move the queen to d2 already
Feels like it's going too far
and that's when this motif begins
queen e5 king i 6 back to 8 may
maybe it means sushi but I suggest
still switch to the party of magnus
because there
on the board is the option that we are with you
discussed which, it seemed to us, was not
quite works for whites i.e. there
a clear crisis now because I can
played the knight beats a6 now they will show us
position after the move and again played
the knight beats a6
yes all once 6 followed by queen 7d and
and here we went with you g7 same 6 yes
he conceived the queen f3 on the knight again in the phase
t5
well then black-black again our
pick up and
but such an unusual sacrifice that is later
on e5 k it looks like White sacrificed
quality on the other hand on black
look at the fields, bringing 6 you're all lying
damn me again go too 6
think so here I am 6-6
here are two pawns customers hanging
loyal would be 8 if we have 61 until i
gave herself to pick up fret
come in pick up you can lose both
elephants have words and c1 protect the fetus by
two queens on this resource one just
black
hold on and I would also like such a question office
d6 there was no move there okay yes then
what moment well nothing almost afternoon and
first b5 rook 6 essential there there
diabetes became our servants 1 before this
in this situation White needs to somehow
I will avoid that is, bundles of 1 is too much
gives a lot, well, just too much
the pace gives up to black only one hangs
Shah there she was kissing and that is the need
look for some option where black is not
beat on one how to achieve it
it is not clear and not 5 but I tried bit 5 and
to walk the elephant e3 then that didn't work either
wait for the sake of justice
someone queen move 3
a little clumsy or maybe already
is to perform differently fall back on the same
what or say up to 4 on the horse and 5 to play
in ten because now on anya
this one is very well immediately recognized
the concept was up to that rook 6-7 but
let not three
positional we play well sometimes
the figure is strong what is it part of
he figure nasty in the first place plugs
bets like that to give away the queen is also not
seems
I can't think of a way for now here's Aronian
Haven't played for 6 already, which worries me
you know, I can't get over the feeling that
we do not see what is very simple after 6
other country what alternatives are also not
quite understandable, because if you don't
you play 6 is not just necessary
retake
arrange figurines for a new batch
because she wanted to restore the parties on
board but I already think I'll get confused somewhere 15
move someone entered slates 1 slide 2
slide 3 slide 32
I'm not sure if I can recover
I need to rush tell me what's there
really going on people
armed and technical
what about the second such pallet -
looks like enough to me
he was confident, no matter how it seemed that
him such a poker face until really
in fact, we know that when positions and not
like it so apparently enough
I'm nervous right now, it's just clearly somehow
forgot for 6 we had a problem and
suspension gave one
you need to change to a2 and in this
variant hangs laden and 2
so we retreated on the floor by
diagonals as much as 5 to 1 so that there are 2 rooks
protected
not very clear, that is, yet again
the best version was to go
through d5 on knight 5 go filter you on
horse and 5 to take on t5, maybe
after rook 6 and exchange on a6, well, drag
rook at 32, that's the problem
you really can't see anything but
this sequel would be nice
probably if it were not for the queen one very much
strong refutation of the option that
rook b2 will follow of course
necessary because white is playing to win
I would venture to suggest that this is for whites
it might not be worse than that
strange with a queen
coins pawns then not very good at fighting
but seriously believe that white is playing
doesn't seem to win either.
possible then all the lemon time I don't
I see, well, it doesn’t matter 17 17 for 17 minutes
remains, of course, the critical
position is likely to be 6
nutricia
I'm trying to find an alternative to go the same 6
to be honest, not very, very
it turns out the retreat is weak
could it be
then true white elephants 3 can lipstick
and elephant e3 no this is nonsense some kind of slates
5 serve to enter the nazi 5 up to
at least there weren't elephants 3, but it wasn't either
does not inspire confidence such a move here
we are prompted by this chat option
which we have not considered
protect just a horse with a fergie
4 on the same 6
the same 4-ku negative and for 4 but this is the one
this is a pretty river can on b4
she is rook 8, apparently we have a move, but
it's beautiful on boat 8 we have though
layer e3 looks like
although also not no they are guaranteed yes
there someone starts before 4
for 4 CDs
looks like this one for whites works from 30
I exchanged many questions in this
the moment it also seemed that the white even there
give actually killed just extra
pawn in a nutshell absolutely
won step 1 and does not lose a6 c7
fm two years do not win at all those here
after all, 100 is worth removing a pawn from under
fight play b4 but yes absolutely right
our viewers in the chat is white's position
more than satisfied and probably exactly
Is that why he thought about it here
looking for some alternatives
give yourself 15 minutes
the end of the party
what to do what is here intact
the most pleasant yes it seems to me
nevertheless, the grip is forced, and only then even
then what do really resource
that you can just jump to
queenside can be original
was missed by the way
that we will return to the final party there
something goes on like a machine gun
lyatsya like a machine gun plays maxim
fast maxim
again I noticed when he is so fast
I think he plays
humbled under the desperation position
so dissatisfied dissatisfied with myself
so after the same 5 was played c3
king is already 2 and black has king d6
walk
when the martyrdom starts the king runs away
somewhere like this
denote up to that somewhere on d2 it
wants to come running white plays on this
about f2 f3
well, the question is queen e5 does not seem to be very
good luck zafer ziv 8 before taking on and everything
sherkhan king d4 on that's any of it
perdo curious position such but unlikely
Does she suit whites so well for
entertainment can show what's going on
queen on each side but I suspect
up to which whites get pretty fast
checkmate must receive from at least
so stage by all laws so it is
happens although I remember at the time
great impression on me
produced a study by Oleg Pervokov where
in the final position on each side
under 2 queens and the player goes it's quiet
moves here it's just impossible even
reproduce well, let's say there
some suggestive
checks that lead to nothing
and it's played like it's a quiet move game
no guys play impossible no
believe, but nevertheless such positions
exist, but here it’s just a magician
my yes that is but king h3
office h1 just and king g4 this
something was confused by the most simple ether to 32
he runs to f5 just about from income
definitely even 1 and 2 to more
5 do not give yes well, that is, it is clearly not
good for whites trying some race
yes, that is, whites should try
still declare a perpetual check, and now if
such a position arises but somehow further
try to check
and by the way, it’s curious that after the exchange
queens now let's say white is given
freesync first is no longer possible
muzzle j on that white speculate
true dad spheres here m corr hives 3d
pretty nasty it can because neither
oddly critical option to be
because let's see after
queen e5 again if black plays
Yes, Fritz 5 is playing from black
giving these shahid studing will queen d8
yes well done 6
and 8 well now frs b
but then again, that's the whole problem
the board ends yes, that is, here is the check
queen by 5 should have been given, but there
not anymore
vertical i.e. wool must go
that's somewhere in that direction and then 7
the letter that is before a yes there is six not
something there 5 from there give a step then this
there would be an eternal step, well, here is the edge of the board
this is often also bios before queen 8 went
forward pass somewhere somewhere king
you still have colleagues, but
here the party is not for quality and skit is a swindler
up to 3 to eat maybe it's two well
the main thing is that the whites do not have time to race in
this date sang does not have time to take on and
to all this position was to you in a hurry to all
such a thing arose yes then of course
killed good odds because at the right time
the moment they're there pawn the same night come on
let's try then I'll be back again for 80 b2
and here to FSB if I have some
a successful edition where we can be proud
porch one now sit down for everything well
of course it looks quite project 2 and
same 6 some chance practically if u
me in this quite by the way yes well that is
here we go shah shah from where here and
step here and it seems to me the paint of the king
adjusts to where he needs more
checks no home gotta pretty fast
there are questions there yes here if
if black has a forced mate here
still your own king on d1
hinders plans a little, wait alone
queen plays d2 check
this is such a serious question
probably prefer xena d2 king
try to pass look what dean did
instead of what we suggested queen d2
the check was played after f3
the maxim falls on the error line
because going first means that
somewhere the queen will be in check, that is, this
even worse darkin 3 just lose
the second one will only have three accounts up
position king h3 had to be created
and now I don’t have for and for attention to
unfortunately there is an attempt to pass again
yeah go ahead for that's the king t5 there
queen b7 king c4 here collected on and
all king of accidents 4 or up to 3 yes there is a question
Yes, who more accurately calculate the shiki wait a minute
king d5 shah sb-700 by chance no ali
then through c4
yes because perry is king for and 4
you get buddha shahnovich you are completely out of
beads were me the same thing long time ago
I read it to 4 I like it more I don't know
why is there an explanation for the husband
I didn’t understand any happiness right there
going on
that is, for Shah Ali what becomes 2
queen b7 always changing
mysteriously
not really, maybe there motors 65
ic2 and then c1 we have poppy there to burn and
c2
now here shah begins prefer zen
same 5 is not entirely clear how to escape from
eternal is not sure far is it right
but where you run away is not very clear
how roles 3 will be especially unfortunate yeah
because black was supposed to have 2 queens
it seems that none will pass
the sense that a new one will not pass and we will lose 100
you know the preponderance is colossal to us galen
chat on win this position after all
necessary
let's go back to magnus what did he do
Magnus was still played by Ivan 6
let's switch to there he is there
seems to feel much more
meaningful opposition that is, we still
we will call more figures from the lion at 9
minutes left in the game against the mongoose
Of course, this is an additional factor.
in such a difficult position so come on
once again cavalry 5 5 took our hearts
sindo yes and 6 this is exactly the option
discussed fergie 4 candida e5 queen 4
and get along 8, that is, White has an extra pawn
that conceived it for services 3 but I'm so
I understand that up to 4 of the last forces yes no
very clear
you really need to get scrapped not 3
planned
no, but I already think so
actual problem with londa four white
the queen is taken while it seems still not
Tula Debut 6 Until Zafer Meetings
reducing 8 if I don't understand such a dream
maybe tomorrow at the very least an elephant
detritus is still an e4 bishop, which one is such
transformation which can also be
would be advantageous for white but bishop d3 bishop
up to 3 seems to me just enough
in addition, in the case of bishop e3 d4 and create
really looks good that is
the feeling is already some kind of attempt
catch what is called fish in troubled waters
that objectively the position is close to both
right end 4 can
somehow jump
that included dress up 4 here including
this transition seems to me rather
total wins rook beta 4 water beta
4 up on the white get apparently
melody for a queen before plus some pawns
no end 4 it seems to me where you are 4.4
try to trade at e3, at least
some multicolored use
. devout residents flowers until stuck
figures each if only 5 just don’t tell
they will most likely give a battery scrap
you can weakly play 3 at least
keep both pawns
they took they took it and it seems they didn't
reach the black target radio 8 like
there's just a move at the end of 5 I don't see it yet
how to refute it yes they show us
maxima and denali do not look at the maximum
sage some quiet ode to do in this
position is fantastic
no now they will switch us to dropped there
true magus a lot of time he will still be
yes, but given that Leon has stayed in
nine minutes I think we should
watch this game until the end
you can see us until you decide us
moments
yes, it's clear what's going on here.
Well, I guess there is some choice.
if you think about it white has nothing
hanging white here including may there
walk to be four do absolutely absolutely
I can't find anything to buy
gathering sometime 4 black apparently must
change more accept no change
then you want to read
take on and 5k
catch but that's the one I liked the idea
sun 3 if she works there
Impossible to [ __ ] show the same
we have 6 this number is not so gone not you
was also 6 orders more
convincing childhood rook 8 can
probably stop
the figure is just superfluous not a8 dirt it
dream of friction is given by fires, which means
it remains what us military stephanie hangs
elephant on be four types of olya 2 5 to 5 to
4 you can play yes this is probably
a fair remark would be from so
quite honestly, that's what it's not
especially the position of the water to beat two elephants 6
you are not here of course your bottom pole
jump catch stones six jump
just a fight
in full swing bf5 probably even yes
I agree it's like this like this it's possible and
release but for now purges
clearly objection to bishop e3 is not for me
can not see
there is no doubt that the position is won
honestly burst
well let's go to sleep e 3
considered can 4 considered yes
yes 4cd
although I was not convinced, but here
I don't even see a convincing vision
elephant to 4 only ah yes king 2 well
suppose 2 maybe there are some
arguments in favor of f1 there but for now
it is not clear yes the horse beats
d4 and so I planned with the queen to forget about
and the sun 5 is not here, the elephant is c5
4 will give according to the feeling
not visible when not to mention that
similar such a move is it beats 5
they took away something that I imagined
chase canyon kuni 4 there queen 6 it
continues to say it without not
these wars and tactical injections are endless
impossible to stop up all the time
want someone new new tactics
count probably therefore actually
Magnus and thoughts, that is, it is also not for us
prompt d4
elephants 44 we consider in this
positions will be born 4 yes and here it is
competently by the way brought 4 then the horse
f3 yes this is an important interval and the bishop to 4
not so good
disperse here we sit here these here
there was this move going well 4 days which
I think blacks are in big trouble.
I don’t know, maybe you went to compose a horse
but this dice 2 feels like before service 3
tells us about the weakness of the pawn, all of it
costs like
but hope somewhere leaves but positions
objectively it seems to me
drank throw nothing especially hangs and
between the next move there's not some
some kind of transition protection laggards
shelving 3 3 striker on and that's all
it's so here to cling to life yes
it is clear that some whites will have to
pitfalls to bypass but it is not visible
special doubts why yes why
White should not be won like this
question about one guest
player in the Candidates Tournament, we are already
really touched on this topic.
or a couple of days ago here goes a lot
disputes whether this is fair or not, but again
seems completely fair
a system that would not break the rules
sports selection at the moment me
it seems not because the tournament
applicants
need to organize a big
prize fund and it seems to me like this
way up try the organizers
lure something potential
additional for additional
sponsors organizer but again
wild to gin is not just given
to any chess player who is in
will play it this year
that is, next year then Kirill
alexey paint still i don't remember if
he will not get through the selection through the grand prix
and again, they deserve it
play
play the Candidates Tournament
yeah well that is it in any end man
receiving a wildcard here in the current
the system is someone who almost got selected
yes, who did not have quite a bit
here of course to say yes
probably the ideal would be a system where
all players would be selected from
on the principles of how we are the boundaries of sports
selection from any tournaments yet
there is a system such
really won't go away
maxim does not pass unless it is from
is taken from the Grand Prix and yes that is, it is not
will receive a wild card but on the other hand
What's stopping him from playing well?
the last stage to exit, as it were, let's say
additionally, of course, Russian
chess player is given an extra chance
but let's say kirill alexey nko in tournaments
he did not play the grand prix very well
spoke
grunge looking for doorman throw me what
seems like a pretty legal right
send them there by the organizers
save
[music]
such an opportunity to give wildcats and
Russian chess player, let's go back
again, I saw some
option but still
finally how are we going to see ourselves go
karlsson's income is still not an elephant before 4 queens
not yet gone myself not 3d owners
four days not here not here I'm already
got confused and then horses horse f3
here of course rome is a crazy option
again on the same 27 there is such an opportunity
and probably there is but it is not very clear to me
it seemed that in this case up to 5 have time
white yes well up to 5 years conditional 4
ponyville and if nadia 66 but I'm trying
will continue somehow the option to give everything away
very somewhere carson thinks about it yet
did not find a clear path to victory
denli zhen think we can try
take a break while that's still lets
time is not quite yet not quite yet
right in color time pressure and that's judging by
all of us broadcast director allows
let's take such liberty for a while
take a break just run up to do
a sip of water will be back in just minutes
stay with us both in ten
the party is still going on
[music]
but it costs many people do
our online from indonesia
and again they are strong
1000 ha homs problem borisa saw a black
in this one from whose a I ran and ubisoft and how
politics
and someone say riku will block hu
schoolbag children given ikea springen
she everybody's fool in history on audix
applying very remember
always belt
then Dr. juridico
[music]
we retreat michael to the ground or
spiritual gift
[music]
myself
no flour kira astronautics
or cracks in the old
things
and I basically play very games tks bank not
sleeping book bag in the ocean liner
english what site iphone lego sumo not
stories.
patchouli to study martial
[music]
here
believe
enticing aroma.
[music]
boots
I changed
till
5 in 1 you will play the shawl
put there
for home
covered in mist
two will be up
yea 1h stone for award winning dancers
[music]
i write tegumai samaritan released
a set of paper I grew up it is conspicuous.
mine and stitches away from here
the market is pretty
[music]
us dry peresa and valleys without a box
white module im pain engels
y movie and nissan dolphin 22nd one
inspected bedouin namely pinkie
pie
[music]
hurry up oh site messages least
you contacts korea they
move over and
[music]
mum
baby lyamkin so
[music]
he owes
where are the swimmers 10 spears
Julia pasa give us
then and
antimage
let's see sergei amin bakunin
frying pan minute as we carry
[music]
but
Well let's continue today
remind 1
the classic game is being played today in
final of the Grand Hour Tour in London and in the match
for third place both parties are still
continues it seems that there is determined
already a position in the party of magnus carson
against Levon Aronian a and y maxim
kilos look like serious problems
against denali don't remember what prizes
after all, in this tournament what is worth
how much will the winner get
a lot of money 150 thousand dollars if I don't
wrong up to 100 thousand for the second place and
another 100 played in the match for the third
place the winner will receive the match but
the winner of the match for third place will receive
$20,000 more
and good chances that it is Magnus
carlsen will be the winner
match for third place
interesting solution very interesting
Magnus made the decision, let's go back to
party carson aronian
respect the kilograms are still there
the queen's spire is still early there
back there yes in the party of Aronian a
after the move from the moon 3 was played to 4
elephant dd4 here will teach pointed to
opportunity get along 4 yes it seems to me
at that very moment, but the levon passed
past the entrance get along 4 not for either
for some reason it didn't work well in
in general, the lemon gave a check on f3
king 2 took on t4 that's you
we looked at the e6 knight here curiously
because it seemed that you can retreat
on a4 there is still somewhere magus just
donated exchange played vladya beats
e6 f.u.
and put an elephant and 4 and right here
it turns out that's how it often happens in
games of magnus carlsen what do i think
out of the blue it turned out that all the figures
blacks are essentially paralyzed let's
let's check one by one Vanya doesn't seem to
Bishop c5 moves
I would not argue that the bishop is c5
you can walk but pack if the sun is 5 i
I suspect that 5 cavalry is needed
consider and after taking on one
some move knight d7 though I'm not really
I understand who we are creating a threat if so
6 honestly up to 25 move there is undoubtedly
veiled little squash in 2
then to the left but apparently not playing slates
5 then we be queen b7 no matter how
strange no steel queens 735 there a couple
checks 25 took well, by the way, it’s not clear
maybe it's at least until the end
hopeless situation candy 7 move then
of course yes menacing actually move
knight f6 until it's one scarf panel out
maybe in this case
it was possible to continue the game where successfully 3
drive and stroking 2 knights f6
king and everyone took on f6 took on
kiss but whites are better, well, it's still
the party didn't end somehow
retreat this queen yes or maybe not
whites are better in general quite curious
well aleah wang played before levon played
deev 8 aiming pawns at 2 before can
not so figure black and paralyzed as
I announced here well to 4
or how we play
gave gay 8 some sense of posing
the threat of the boat of the highway scored quite
do nothing there goes h4 for example
yes, it looks like you can take queen 7 on 6
size on 7 Icelandic 5 and then on f2 on
d2 everything sags there, well, white doesn’t
must skip a move yes, that is, you can
move d4 consideration
again slender 30 perfect you
position itself can say passed sony 4
us inside
don't quite see no play here
inside protect the horse 6 up
but you don't know, it seemed to me that the water
hits her six it's just so elegant and
right decision and now I'm starting
think about whether it was necessary whether it was impossible
it was somehow to play more restrained that
whether
was there really no field for the queen but
it was possible at least queen 4 yes
try curious
well, as if the strap 20 did not want
give to b2 took away moons climbed 4
good water
8 but now according to the material yes for white
that is, there is not enough quality for it two
pawns but somehow not yet perfect
arranged figures
here's a little rethink, maybe
listen deserves kite criticism
Carson's solution is just so continue
implementation
threatens to threaten the wielding statue
affected by the arrival of dash capitalization
I'm not sure about this, but because 7 are suitable
min and in the end still there is this between
Thomson will separate Volodya more from the steppe and
because they did terrible for whites
give 4 bought and don't be this business
white tiger 22 would have that lair a6 already
I don't think there is just how
ideas because there is no care slates 5 on
which everything was kept by white cloaks not
empty 2 extra pawns and don't know about
some absolutely won position
there are tricks going on well in general yes in
Overall White should have a decisive advantage
and do what to do on b4 but somehow
try to get out of the corner with these
figures
how to do it another
simply
elephant
out of 7
January is still hanging
who has one even until we load the rooks
again there are sets of four by four
it is important to control the c5 square, yes, because
how can you be in the same water again
nicola de broth there while on f2 protect
White a couple more moves I think they are
fully establish interaction now
black would like just some
demonstrate tactical skill
all this is a tactical show-off
again, we are prompted in the chat
for some reason on b4 rooks everyone goes black
and everyone is defending queen 7 and now they want
take our rubbers force the whites to go
with mandates well, what can be no longer
tragedy up to 3
and now you can sort of remove the radius
6 brings 6 although this is the ending
can be very, very annoying
not entirely clear 3 the truth hangs will give
Magus announced that Magnus wins everything
somehow it looked looked to be white
very good actually can be and
it seems to be on time, too, with him
18 minutes left what will we have
so colored hot yes it will be
will be like time trouble in both
parties let's see what else
semi-final I wanted to say this is the final
what happens in the final
real final match yeah your
kilogram against denali is not and therefore
that I found some practices so far
the Chinese fail
finally decided to say so
finally decide how
win there was a curious moment in
now I'll show you wait in d2 check
king h3 here is the position on move 48 to me
it seems we have seen will give curious what
Dean has less time already
there was a moment left for maxim
20 minutes left audi for almost an hour
now let's compare well, and apparently not
can pass the king in the period to remember
what control all the same in classic
party we are given 2 hours 10 minutes from
delay
three thirty second delay on
so this odd ratio
time is waiting for us all the time already
everything is no longer unusual
in both cyclops and through with some
40 buries 40 the move has already been completed in this
party kraz it's all right
it's amazing that Aronian and there they are
my only 40 move did dow
and this crow is not over anymore
will never end yeah well that's just how soon
be able to actually look at the board
I think it's the second time it's the same
a position arises there gives shah maxims and
something udino can't get through
king forward to already quite sure
the second time repeated the position and
for some reason you don't play king 4
did not play here, finally let me remind you
what was said asia 4 still needed
give up the pawn on e5 and here's the thing
64 it seems 5 they are here our sleeve he is not
played k rulitsya 4 we are with you
considered instead king d4 king co
by taking on and all the check and even in that
variant apparently something did not work there
not because something did not grow together after
king 3 well let's see by freely
the final dali showed the board yes here I am
wanted to draw attention to the curious
moment here after king h3
queen i.e. after king t5 yes max
found a curious move of such a queen in 5 to
not letting the king in
on t4 actually and that's what happened
king c6 king up 6 some
triangle black write out king
which is very typical for graduation but not
for queens exit kachaev surprised me
this mafia in 5 just persisted
opportunity to play say yes 722 and
win the queen of the king and with it
keeping the threat first from 7 to but and here
maxim gives shaxov 8 king c6 king would
5 here it is not very clear why let's say
the king does not go to a4, and then, well, then
why not try to go say on t1
us behind the flint chair once again
yes this here i app hear from
fiance when he analyzes i hope
that our judgment reaches you
king 15 is already appearing for the second time
queen b7 but also how to justify
attempts goes to d4
but ferdy 4 yes of course critical
continuation of queens and 5 what is there
in mind on c4 now something is like this
the feeling that he just got rid of a pawn
e5 yes, now we’ll actually find out mine
together with maxim because maxim is not
especially doubts moves queens 4 king
c5 strict single according to the rules
chess and take the second pawn and
so short 4 are played
pawn e5 you know i suspect that
but this is quite stupid I suspect
that here is one of the possible states
understand how to do it before sopi 4 checks
no so wait
because it is impossible to give
mine 4 on the king to 4 yes that is in the same place
what happened in the previous
save the previous place the king d4 and now
here mine 4 now the king gets on
c4 and any proper check any move here
one we go if to e4 then
and if the check on e400 can be through d4
meaning
then queen out of 5 to keep the king out
allow c2 to move and keep carolina out
its dates here just again wanted
say what should be
to avoid such a thoughtless just shahov
I don't need three will most likely yes
rather all blacks win here already
next to give shah the king just goes to
to the white king, the pawns begin to fall there
so she and on and 4 can walk king b3
our
taxi 4 find king b31
and how that's interesting at 3 to
like two to black most likely here
it come over goo on one then well
actually
the same one there is a cap will show it is not clear
what pro greek progress black
achieve through
getting rid of the pawn e5
Well, now Maxim will think
understand what is the difference king
our 3 stands very securely
to say something is not usually the same
the problem is what that black starts
close with the queen and for a moment
give the contour of the mine here while the pawn is alive
f3
another point I was thinking about is if
we assume that somehow
it's coming back come on here's another i'm doing
stupid moves for White, but just to
show what the logic is
getting rid of the pawn is that in some
moment king e5 king in 500 never
it turns out generali 5 here and shaxov 6
if they continued what kind of shahida
white she out of 5 there knives 5 maybe
somehow it would be possible to understand yes but from above
me endings are pretty kinda here
history because with the advent like this
in Russian called tables before tables
burbot and so on, but in general, when
with limited material there are 6 figures
on the board right away the computer without even counting
the position is simple and does not know the ready answer
yes yes and that's for the Czech game and became
quite comical to watch because we
understand that everyone is wrong, yes, but here
often also the strongest grandmaster
playing the computer while here was won
won won then 1 mark
changed and, moreover, 5 over 5
there was a draw, then again it became
won when looking at the board
the feeling doesn't change at all
some random shah king from them
runs from the point of view of the highest truth before
assessment changes dramatically
I'm all because even if in some
moment pops up assessment that's all
draw boards still need to do sometimes it
not just a banal eternal step
some quiet moves olya that's how
Maxim found queens at 54 back, but now
it is necessary to check that the thing here is a relay
or karol bak 3-4 why don't we
liked
somehow lost a pawn, yes, it seems, no, not 35
here 5 yes a a b e 5 still walking and 405
we go like this like this i like it
because now the mystery is under control
keep under attack and both pawns too
create some mine king d3 can
be exactly what it means
indeed with the variant king bo3 he
could go straight to b3 without giving up a pawn
e5 if reminded of the queen b7 had the right
play whats up king c5 pepper and 7
let's say king 4 seems to be passing
further on b2 yes it seems to be impossible
be on king c5 true
shox there m maybe this one
constantly d4 passes in general i
already confused and so clear what's what
same ding woo the king of hell the king would
three yes all the same it seems to me we are with you
considered the option king b3 and then
117 gives that is generally the king would you
I don't think I've ever seen rain there
which is completely screen fsb 2
it's nothing at all to settle MP
in my opinion this is done from b-52 and first and
5 is just perpetual check right away what
3 queens will be covered 5 dana the king would be three
first and 5 then look at 3 at 3
goes for some reason
if for one that the king is driven by 4
visa for 11
king a4 some these days then s4
sighs all control is lost over
process in my opinion
sense we have long lost the feeling of the same
their members lost control a little
over the process
before the queen one king would 4 1 game on
allocated so much
Maksim Degas was so surprised by his ideas
same 4 same 5 shorter 2 covers was great
played
very good almost all chances with
the other side
probably in the strongest way
he defended himself with his nails at the checkout, I think
case beast zillo inter peeling very
difficult in the strongest way will be the one
level to reach
if it saves yes, well, that is absolutely
definitely posed very unpleasant problems
so shox b1 and the king goes to c5 then
there is still an idea to play harris d 5
on the queen in 5 US
such a concept was already such
possibility after no such possibility
we did not have in the 4k version the role of c5 holding
c3 pawn in sight yes no and we are with you
tried to get a drill position on d5
so we went through d4 and on
queens 5 I say that here through d5 to me
like it here at dean now maybe
arise the same position only with
king on c5 before after check first and 5 then
there is only the position of the black is different
king instead
c4 in that previous variation is now
will fasten until not on the nuances
plays out it's the pace of the field we'll see
over the party man we turned on he got on
there was very little time left before
switch there too
curious events happened magnus not
played b2b 4 at that moment when we
discussed on the move of the rook f8
reacted rook 2 defending the b2-pawn but
and potentially there f2 due here on
in fact, it looks like you could take
our
[music]
always you remember just a talking about
this option
and how does white hold up
if rook 8 is absolutely right there is a move
rook a8 which me and put yes here
completely forgot that is me and
took into account that lo gay 2 most likely
you can't yes because you don't own 2
connected only and also connected solve a
accordingly for some reason completely
forgot to move rook 8 to sun 5 to all
absolutely correct then
black will play they pool is big here
the question is, of course, if you take it, but apparently
wounded was ready for such a development
events somehow beat stuck figures but
there will be a queen at 3 on occasion
lunge in general magnus syllables b7 exchanged
on 7 and played b2b 4
threatening to run just a pawn forward I
so well and here lemon went sky 8 such
funny move outlining moisture by the way
big apparently white want like
opposition katy c4
this is without a plot 4 c5 although along the contour
I wanted 4 c5 or b5, whatever
like if ring 6 does not come out at least
free puts the duty to protect
our
for 4 I'll get out of the straightening idea
cling so protect the knight by 6 to 5
the question here is whether blacks can somehow
say
give away some of the materials it is not clear how he
goes out and so despite 4k 4th cha
224 played this option yes this
I also thought it was an option
and the number of 4 knight 4 would give the opening two
candidate two horses is not in any way
catch and not even win the c-pawn
because after say water bo2 cavalry
3 goes yes and somehow white grouping
threatened already when one weasel 3 go
after which, of course, after which it will not succeed
the winner of some of the rook's move would
4 even then most likely after c4
most places about feeling if here
there is nothing specific here
such killed their colossal superiority not at
lemon it for the last minutes
property just see now
game for a delay of 30 seconds but it looks like
that the position is already very, very difficult
left to Aronian and so
unexpectedly crying crying here what
they want
play the classic game
yes it could be both
effective this maxim is not true yet
left hopes of a draw to escape but also
it looks pretty dangerous out there
if any recent practically
the chances of this position and do not really understand
Is he looking for he has seconds left there
well, well, probably all the same b5
gotta call she good rook by 6 5
given as later
how then with the move c5 y gave or 6 plays
that is, white stabilizes maybe
just lurking elephant elephant c8 let's just say
well then knocked down they are bound to call a
win immediately this positions play
water up 2 date ml18 well it's take on 6
it will be necessary to rely, no doubt, but
it is clear that the position is just a pawn
on and colorful of course, but at least
some practically then I agree
it certainly didn’t pass instead
give up failed to do better also
ali out while the king played and everyone
he wants to bring the king closer
to be on c5 there is wanted 15 is not stewed
elephant crash on ti5 sun pint bye chunks
dirt of the face killed himself, what will I ask here and then
case here
yes, and you’ll get it right with the number of horses
our
delays atlanta yes that is magus
should try to find the most more
exact let's say so cute day and 2 to may
be worth thinking oddly enough
in general, a movement on the royal
some bye bye bye
Black has no radioactive counterplay
it can be seen that the boats do not move h3 h4
so a magnus plays rook a 20 ml dressed
so you wait gives that is to beetle
126 looks like 56 of course they took it and
the pawn immediately goes to c5 c6
and this is of course serious and strengthening here too
again, with such a structure, you know
at some point it may turn out to be sibur
white has time to play let's say from h4
fix something on white margins even
without vladimir to be beneficial to the school but
however it looks like instant surrender
instant victory carson is not here
will follow the party
will be delayed which gives us every right
switch to 2 for the second batch for now
the water has reached the sc5 position now
let's see where the lemon can not at you
there is absolutely no essence all the same I will go to the boat
b2 not bad, yes, why did I start this one
talk about what could be
count all the same, here are some by
villainous until the end that is
potentially if white plays c6 water
7 each held by ledger nano and king
trying nasty
or one way or the other and out
the bishop is put on e5 just in case
hindering this words 2 move yes here
the question is whether they want to include white in 4 more
it is very similar that, again, the position with
huge chances of winning with huge
chances to win but still to come
actually for adding 6 come on
let's see with the movie queen's ending there
some kind of critical position
arose your have a dynam and judging because
that for a long time there is no waste there, too
was satisfied with little time for all sorts
6 minutes still so mean after all these
shakhov shaxov 5 we saw yes now i
I'll try to show as soon as they give us
board this position is already on the board
quite a long time ago five minutes so sure
din duma before after check and 105 queens in 5
check was played with 8 step g4 finally
the king must have run away 3 and now it's five 6
here is such a question, it means there is a move c2
and something gives me the feeling that maxim
claims that there is no mate here
it happens in general chess maybe it
believe that one of the parties will be here
to have a possibility
1 start insuring and at the same time will not
there were probably no queens 5 5 in theory everything
must end well yes it is fashion
ferdy 4 step and
there is shox h5 for such a move
so that 70 hangs both queens yes you can
don't panic just don't go
there may be some gap on c2
maybe after c2 dawuda actually i
what I wanted to say is there an option
direct sc2 and then something white is already there
have to choose either if
for some reason it doesn't work black can
pick up on the 6th floor have a good chance
to implementation because well now
the pawns are definitely nowhere before the whites before
starts to give shaheen u22 very
attractive option clear immediately check
there is no successful, as if unsuccessful, like
there would be no yes but if you try
put the cutter on f8 is also nothing
we’re changing, not because it hung there
queen knives 8 posters and oh this one can
be you have nothing when she's like no
wait well sho ks-e 555 protects the cutter
there all queens will come once at 4 when
you come to the pub knives cheats
maybe some absolutely incredible
positions analyzes cow 4 matlet
but of course I can't find it
where is he again somewhere there is a mod or maybe
to be and you would be important it doesn't happen that
with two rests, fog can be
in some magical way we graze
right at this end
and then from here shah what do we do she
we lead back our until reached if it
in general yes if possible
against against all the rules I will say so
hear it tells me
our technical team what's not here
mata no mind from already mouth draw what is it and
this is most likely the same
and saves the whites here this is
that the characters are 80 but it seems to me so as not to
hung version already 8 there is the main one
the problem is that
dream and the main difference is that queen 2
Yes, there are some fields along the line in the control
up to 2 still leads to a draw
then what to do it is necessary to beat the two of them
goes ticks
it is necessary to finish off already something salary 6
but apart from 3
the junction of the pawn is still on f3
well then take one of the bf3 steps
he is thirsty, then you can lose such
no training should be the same c2
it will still end what to do
given to life g6 how then how
win continue the game it is clear how
continue playing check same constants i'm here
just tried with quality here from
the miner is 1 and you can't take on f3 nice 2
game 1 that is we really
we will remain with similar witnesses of this
fantastic completely position where by
2 queens and at the same time there is no match, yes we have it
didn't find it incredible is if you
found it's not scary that's if we
really prompt our
whose technical team is equipped
engines, I suspect that there is already
quite confidently masculine, but this
fantastic absolutely position where
completely divine
divine remember solemn
a look told us nothing
divine eye can tell
watch i thought your i was watching
any feminine look so
to say no tells us just like that
already ax h1 before that we have reached our
development good king same 3 what now
nothing should be so boring
still sho xiii 535 at least in cheats before
fergie f4 strictly the only one seems to be yes
Magnus there meanwhile so reminisce about
the fact that we have 2 goes park the magus
built such an unforgiving
hand here you know brings greetings
it seems to me that there is already difficult
imagine how all the same aranin will jump off
Is it possible that fortune will be fulfilled to him at most
[music]
I think I've smiled a lot
it seems poker meter terminology
we varnish good but at least once to him
lucky the final stage no matter how
it seemed to me that actually maxim
luck would be more important, oddly enough
say not in this tournament in the grand prix he
I myself would probably prefer
to be selected as a contender but here
undoubtedly win the tournament in which
which goes here is a whole year series
tournaments win a tournament
magnus carlsson play too
will surely be a great day to play
come on let's not forget all the same something
this is not a victory in the tournament
just run away for a draw with white fortune
definitely smiling yes but still needed
work out advances I think what if
Maxim will live to see the fast and
table he is certain
Undoubtedly says why because
so day because ding that's not quite
confidently plays the sound is no longer sure
playing man you won the tiebreak u
carlsson exactly the same as maxim i'm here
here Sasha disagree back his hands
Maxim's hands are shaking, he is not shaking
keep calm until the very end
amazing cold blooded shows to be
I don't see just how blacks can
watch can play landscape 1 time not
win 31 such once again give check the same
one of f2 there how white holds up too
go to live there our 3 no don't understand
we are not on the analytical board are we not
we can sort out the options for now, let's
cameras let's see udino last minutes
remains has been played
fer same one king from 4 to and here
it seemed to me to say something basic
cities
you go you go our 4 this this this
it's unbelievable that mapo is not needed here
the outcome of queens 1 and there is even a move of queens one
but you're in h4 now
there is no additional mine here
this fantasy is complete
so ding gives shox e1 queen now we
we'll see the king same 4 shox h4 weapon no
3 years option we considered that
does maxim hold up
just really fantastic
you know honestly go crazy and lose
already this position
go crazy and not necessarily completely
queened abundantly with an extra pawn to water
that checks are 5 Firtash 5 before the king in
six is ​​already 6 and strictly uniquely g5
losing yes hold five losing
because the queen is f3 yes there hangs first
on f8 you have to move the queen at 4 and
blacks change one more and on the roofs
have queen h5
lion king 6 well check c3 is step 1 then
have you all waiting for white to win
for the game this will happen no I will come
fantastic will of course
fantastic rescue absolutely for 1 a
for 1 but similar to e6 you can walk
I was already brainwashed from
so many people on the boards i
totally unable to tell the difference
I already have a difference yes well well that is
new 6 so far it's not clear how
refuted dodge ah ha ha 6-3 step up
ti2 with 2 give check then most likely
buildings on f6
it seems that that is, blacks can some
draw a ladder there to reach
c3 oedipus ah yes of course yes and now
go back to yudin quite a bit
no time left with you
I agree about the fact that Dean has hands
tremble still that all this is also very
a strong player like them fast and blitz
so i think it will work out anyway.
on the board they are there in some kind of nerves on
tie break
but you can speculate though
a little bit you already understood your love
French chess player of maximums and
logrov this is already I think that all the spectators
appreciated already so to speak it was rooting for
their impartially so I'm rooting for
one runs just a studio i am not yes
if there is any threat to sing
Marseillaise will be however
it really looks like he's thinking
maxim do we really not see something lived
what that is will present that in this
the positions of the black cat and a quiet move are made
absolutely impossible yes that is after
king e6 black should give click
one step what's the difference next step 1 all
anyway, there goes step 1 at all
stupidity if whites want they can
queens 4 play yes yes it looks like he ran away
to draw your logr fiction of course
just fantastic know I don't tell us
only a lost position can
be and generally controlled but here
recognize up to what with two queens he
running under the blows
king you don't get checkmate it's of course
impressive
Yes, I remind you that we analyze of course
the same party without a computer that is
in fact, we are playing our own part
chess game 2 commenting literally
and trying
analyze the incredible
position up need I don't see the difference
King of the Higher School
here leaning in the meantime it looks like
Carlson's game ends against or
any she will show us before wins
Magnus pointed this out quite right.
what plan will we give there later
let's run and when the queen is over
endgame in the final we will run through the moves
and also in time lost it to the wounded
just in case there are positions
it's the heaviest but also the time the time
overdue Ivan Aronian defeats Magnus
that is, everything is still destroyed, this is it
nobody's on and the curse can be at least like this
in a strange way, but still
win a game in classic i.e. 60
after the first game in the match for the third
a place between carson and wounded so and here
dean just follows mine
covenants with a recipe brings the queen down with a ladder
Magnus fights in this go for ranking
not shangina
in this match
[music]
sunk to feel the connection c3
distant it seems that Dean has already realized that
victory can not be seen really
fantastic absolutely dismount in
performance maxim produces produces
impression undoubtedly back on b2 that
back to e6 somewhere around here most likely
will be a draw
not yet every step for 6 when not yet
no to migration austria your g6 like us
react
that is, you need the correct queen on f6
just such a moment can still close
intrigue is exhausted until the queen of as many as 5 on
White move 6 they have the king in check
if now queen sage 506 no further
it is worth I propose with the queen sage 5 to give a check
to the king on e6, no one decided to repeat
king and w6 and here, by the way, queen d2
will already be three repetitions of another
you can honestly go through the center
need c3 started on 3gs yet
remind remind what what what
the score will be on occasion with a draw and even
draw 3 dc-3 let's see king
I am 6 and of course, well, in this position
serge 6 yes I certainly how much is there
different one another is happiness then
how 8 is needed and there, too, on the verge
by the way, no, too, the health of autumn can s
queen with 8 there appear additional
check on him
and it looks like they should win, I don't know who
let's see g6 played den tod very
curiously plays for a minute and here
I don't know why but I guess how
fusing 1 of 4 and that's maxim play
queen f4 to f6
because the shah has no ferris e4, but
if the queen with 8 went then step and take
sc6 now where
mousse all over e5
oh my god how do you recover from something like this?
party, I don’t represent myself at all and
today is not a secret
for example, they do not understand what it is in what
and that is, for every 7-8 everyone yes yes yes
[ __ ] for the helmet is somehow not really
improves the situation to just unbelievable
[music]
quite cow 6 0 6 5
by category now cow 6 or something yes
queens 5 is still some move
spins 5 5 using what is queen
bound kingdom and still king
e7 let them achieve nothing further
black is fantastic
those feel like fillet even 6
can't use this can
White can even be on d8 now
move away from the queen same 6 out in fact
here's a guess if there is something there
kingside and from the king we run on
queen then it's proper black
attack with a single fergie queen
6 can't take part in this
time to remind that was won
first classic victory in history
final tournaments pottery magnus
carlsen defeated obi-wan before she did
it's all classic parties
ended in a draw
as in the first tournament and in
semi-finals its 2 finals
so there seems to be
some problems yes in this position for
maxim when problem identified
because don't hurry and dismount to me
ask me to ask if I will go with
beatles lover in vladivostok
January and who is a beetle lover
so that I know what choice I make
until I was offered to go to
vladivostok
they won't find short for lovers of beats and
concepts I do not know who is talking about
queens I'm sitting still
well, yes, that is, it also allows queens in 5
like, well, 5 roots 768 on the whole check and
ends yes, that is, you can exchange
all queens on f6 play king e3 and
completely completely destroy the entire
material
king e7 and it looks like y gives no not yet
it doesn't matter how you can give a check
just then give a check with Celsius
really ends the idea is king
e6 absolutely fantastic rescue
simple and wonderful heart 7 step is given before
kings 6 clear strict drive again
affects control will answer if you had
would pressure adding after 40 pics to me
seems
dimka would cope with the tasks
melt to realization wait and not when
reached 40 where 10 minutes forty if not
more yes so I think it is
there you need to check because all the same
Do you remember that it seemed possible at all
had to win without bringing up the queen's
endgame and then there Ferdy was reduced by
feeling black somehow not every chance
used, well, apparently thought that he
wins in this one
positions after c2 couldn't believe that before
that the world is 2 queens so to speak on the board in
attack and I don’t want to, I’m still the same happiness
alive just using that queen
appears on the field and 8 so fest
appear on were eight and
and 2 hours 2 white queens defending each other
dick just can't come to terms reached
Minsk is very difficult of course
laugh with nothing and this situation is everywhere
5 and now it looks like the final one, so
after king e7 through c5 it will be
micros already triple repetition queen
on c5 already been a couple of times
if not queen e5 then not everything is clear wife
doctor yo exchange completely on f6
and play king king e3 destroying
the last white pawn so nevertheless
that's what's important is that it's not on time
lose not commit is typical and you
position
sorry everything is so everything goes to that no everything
Taki through the chains and offered a draw
there's such a here for and protracted 90 moves
continuing
party ends eventually
draw a lot of questions to the opening
training maxims kilograms and much more
as I understand it, Dean has questions to
own technique is clearly upset clearly
frustrated denly is not needed here
show us 33 final score initial
draw in the classics but it's really hard hard
kill blame da ha ha for the lack of so
to say in the absence of a struggle is very
interesting party no doubt on and here
this is a very nice idea
that the king is running away from persecution
two queens
they still look like this ending
look up to king e3 some move there
offers a day there anyway shox h1 same
one yes it seems that maxim found some
and wonderful
and a wonderful idea thanks to which not
manages to win
and so here Dean offers look
run away like a king, but at the same time
the ocean is offered to fire it seems to me
king to 36 and now this position
once again look yes here it seems already
too late to try he that is and to all f5 else
as an option that we have not tested well
well let's look at the score of the match for
third place there seems to lead on
us box office seems to be in the lead after winning
in one single batch
took place no wonder that the leader
magnus carlsen recall 6 points in
classics is given for winning i.e. 60 is
for the price it is a victory equals victories
3 blitz wins before
or one and a half pc lunch and still we
need to be reminded that tomorrow is a tour
starts early let's look at
timetable Yes, this is important to recall in
including ourselves, but here we are
we see the finalists continue to analyze
finalists continue to analyze
let's remind ourselves
imagine that the start of tomorrow's tour
responsibly and not tomorrow's broadcast on
two hours earlier, that is, it is at 5 o'clock
Moscow will begin the second classical
Party at ten minutes to five in Moscow
respectively 5 pm we will start
broadcast if everything goes according to plan
Today we apologize again.
for certain technical problems
who delayed us for almost two hours
but we were ready to comment on any
at the price
so what kind of beatles lover is sergey
shirov on most likely sergey shipov
maybe it's a typo and
I think it hasn't been accepted yet
decision before comment
world championship match
discussed but for now I'm in Vladivostok
no one called me with pleasure there
go or in any other way
I will comment at least well, what are we
then we'll be back on the air tomorrow there
Today seems like it's time to let it down
results again
looks like I missed it somewhere
somewhere missed Denli Zhen Aronian
continues here to continue compassion
Levon Aronian is defeated by
Carlson, of course, the world champion is very
it is difficult to give odds in the whole classical
party, that is, for
earlier she would be very uneasy mother we
back on air tomorrow
reminded two hours earlier look
based on the world i think i wanted something else
add
can't under on wanted to say goodbye to
everyone in the chat, prepare the final
in advance, maybe your questions and we have
and tomorrow there will be more time again 2
classical party we'll try on
all answer
[music]